Three,
two,
one,
and we're live.
What's up?
Right.
Hey Man,
let's go on.
Great.
Sam Harris,
ladies and gentlemen at Harris and
Harris.
Dan and Sam.
No relation,
obviously no relation and brother from
another mother kind of thing.
Aw,
sweet.
Actually know how we work this out.
We are deeply unrelated because you're
your Harris is the Jewish side of your
family,
right?
No,
no,
no.
To my Harris is the Yes to actually,
no,
you're right.
My Harris is the Jewish side of the
family.
It was changed at Ellis Island from
allegedly from Adis,
which doesn't sound Jewish either,
but uh,
yes,
right.
Your heart is the Glam side of the
family.
Funny how many people's names were
changed at Ellis Island?
Yeah,
like what are they like?
Nah,
not American enough.
Meanwhile,
snorts egg made it proudly.
Yeah.
Odd.
So,
uh,
anyway,
thanks for coming you guys.
Thanks for having some weird time.
You know,
I've been extra weirded out over the
last couple months and I just got back
from Mexico,
was on vacation.
I didn't do shit for a week and in not
doing anything for a week,
I really got a chance to sit down and
think about stuff and I'm more weirded
out by life today than I think I ever
have been before.
So I'm excited to have you on because I
want to hear your story because Sam has
been telling me about it and I looked
into it and please explain like what
happened to you,
like where you were and what happened to
you.
Okay.
So it was a,
you're,
you're talking about the panic attack.
It was 2004.
I was on a little show that we do at ABC
news called Good Morning America.
Big shots,
a big show show.
It's not a little show.
And I was,
I was doing the job that I was filling
in as the news reader.
That's the person who comes on at the
top of each hour and reason the
headlines.
And I just freaked out.
I just lost it.
So as a couple seconds into it and I,
I started to get really scared and it
just,
uh,
if you've ever had a pet,
have you ever had a panic?
No.
So it's like anxiety on steroids,
so you start to worry,
but then your fight or flight instincts
kick in.
So,
um,
your lungs seize up,
your palms start sweating,
your mouth dries up,
your heart is racing,
your mind is racing.
You just,
I couldn't breathe and therefore
couldn't speak.
So a couple of seconds into reading what
was supposed to be six stories right off
of the teleprompter.
I just,
I lost the capacity to speak and I had
to kind of squeak out a,
something about,
you know,
back to you,
to the main anchors.
Wow.
That sucked.
Uncontrollable.
No.
What,
what caused it?
I do,
yeah,
definitely know I'm some dumb behavior
in my personal life is what caused it.
I had spent a lot of time as a war
reporter at ABC News.
I was in Afghanistan and Pakistan,
Israel,
the West Bank,
Gaza six,
six trips to and uh,
I had come home from a long run and I
covered a kind of pre-invasion invasion
and then a insurgency in one's kind of
six month run and I came home after that
and I got depressed and I didn't
actually know I was depressed,
but I was having some obvious symptoms
in hindsight.
Uh,
I was having trouble getting out of bed,
felt like that,
had a low grade fever all the time.
And then I did something really smart,
which is I started to self medicate with
cocaine and ecstasy.
Uh,
and even though I wasn't doing it all
the time,
I like to say it wasn't like that,
you know,
you ever see the wolf of Wall Street
where they're popping ludes that that
wasn't me.
I was,
and I wasn't getting high on the air or
anything like that,
but,
you know,
I was getting,
I was partying in my spare time because
it made me feel better.
Uh,
so after I had the panic attack I went
to a doctor who's an expert in panic and
he started asking me a bunch of
questions,
try to figure out what,
what,
what had caused the panic attack and one
of the questions was do,
do drugs,
and I was like,
yeah,
I do drugs.
And he leaned back in his chair and gave
me a look.
That's communicated,
uh,
the following sentiment.
Um,
okay asshole mystery solved.
And he just pointed out that,
you know,
you raised the level of adrenaline in
your brain artificially,
uh,
you,
you make it much more likely to have a
panic attack.
And I at at,
at baseline,
I'm a jittery little dudes so it
doesn't,
doesn't take much to put me in that
zone.
We can just offer me coffee.
And I said no because that even that
will freak me out.
Well,
it's weird that ecstasy and cocaine was
the combination because ecstasy is
something that they actually give to a
lot of soldiers that have ptsd.
And there's been quite a few tests on
that.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't actually think ecstasy was the
problem.
The coke,
I think it was a coke.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
So those are the two drugs I was mostly
doing.
How often were you doing it?
I would say,
you know,
there would be months where I wasn't
doing it at all because I would,
I was off.
I covered the 2004 presidential campaign
that I didn't have a lot of time to be
snorting coke.
So,
um,
but when I was home and around my
friends,
you know,
on a good,
on a busy week,
you know,
two,
three times a week.
Wow.
That's a lot.
Yeah,
that'll do you [inaudible] there's a,
there's a comeback right now that
cocaine is experiencing really ever go
away.
I don't know,
I've never done it.
Was there some sort of cocaine recession
that had to bounce back from?
I believe there was really.
No,
this is what I'm talking totally
ignorant.
I've been out of the game for a long
time,
so yeah.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm kind of boring now.
I'm a,
but it feels to me like it's kind of a
perennial favorite.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
I feel like it went through a recession,
maybe it's just my perception.
I had a buddy of mine when I was in high
school and his cousin was hooked on coke
and I watched while we're in high
school,
we start selling it and he withered
away,
lost like 30 pounds or something like
that and just him and his girlfriend
just hide out in the attic.
They lived,
they had an attic apartment.
They would just hide out there and watch
TV and do coconut oil,
coke to people and I was like,
well
fuck that drug,
whatever that drug's doing.
Like these people.
It was almost like knowing someone who
had gotten bitten by a vampire become
something different.
It was very strange.
So my experience is seeing people do
that led me to never do it.
Yeah,
I mean it certainly was not like that
for me,
but you know,
I,
I could see it over the horizon.
You can.
It's an incredibly addictive drug.
So I think you've made the right call.
Yeah,
it seems a little.
It's got a little too much gravity
attached to it.
Yeah,
I mean,
you,
you can get hooked and it will bring you
down.
There are other drugs you can do.
I'm not recommending drugs,
but,
uh,
the way of my friend Sam,
my,
my half brother,
Sam over there.
Let me get to it.
Uh,
there are other drugs,
drugs you can do that have vastly lower
addictive,
uh,
a character,
a character.
What's the word I'm looking for here?
So,
characteristics.
Yes.
Thank you.
Um,
so how did you recover?
I,
so I wasn't actually doing it that long.
I actually never done hard drugs into my
early thirties and when I came home from
the war zones and,
and that's what started it.
Yeah.
Were freaked out by seeing too much.
No,
you know,
it's actually wasn't ptsd.
Uh,
it was,
I was addicted to the adrenaline I was
having was not that I was traumatized.
It was that I was enjoying it too much
and I would come home and the world
would seem gray and boring.
Uh,
yes.
That was,
that was the problem.
Did you watch her locker?
I'm sure you did it,
yeah.
Did that resonate with you?
It's been a while since I watched it,
but apps,
absolutely.
I want to just be clear that the
experience of a journalist is so
different from the experience,
so much more mild than the experience of
a,
an enlisted man or a woman.
So I don't want to compare my experience
to,
to the hurt locker.
I'm a observer on the side and I,
and,
and I don't even want to compare my
experience to more experienced work
correspondence out there.
I'm thinking of like guys like Richard
Angle and I'm absolutely just actually
sat down with him the other day for he's
got to do documentary coming out.
Um,
my experiences are much more mild than
that,
but certainly enough to really get a
sense of how thrilling it is.
There's an expression,
there's nothing more thrilling than the
bullet that misses you.
And in my case,
luckily they all missed.
That was not true for some of my
friends.
Um,
but you.
So I,
I had a real sense of the stakes,
but 80 is exciting.
It's also thrilling on a,
um,
on a idealistic level.
I mean,
I believe in the importance of bearing
witness to the what,
to the tip of the spirit,
to what we're doing,
to what our military is doing in our
name.
So all of that is a heady mix.
So you knew people over there,
a journalist that got killed?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
A very good friend of mine,
the guy who actually ultimately set me
up with my wife.
It was a guy named Bob Woodruff,
who was the anchor of world news tonight
on ABC News.
He had only been in the chair for about
a month when he was on a trip to Iraq
and he got hit,
literally got his head nearly blown off
when he was in the back when he was in
the top of an Iraqi tank.
Uh,
almost died.
He was an absolute miracle is alive.
There are pictures of him on the
Internet with basically half ahead.
Um,
traumatic brain injury was brought back
to life is to this day walking miracle
that he's alive.
Uh,
and,
and after he recovered,
he then introduced me to the woman I
married.
So he's a close friend and I,
uh,
I saw cases like that,
lost friends,
both Iraqi friends and journalist
friends.
Um,
my,
the woman I was dating at the time when
I,
when I was spending a lot of time in
Iraq,
she got hit by a tank show.
Um,
she was in,
in the hotel Palestine where all the
journalists were staying.
She was on a balcony in or one of her
colleagues in the balcony below or he
got a direct hit and died.
Uh,
he,
she carried him to the hospital and she
basically got the reverberations and
couldn't hear.
Still can't hear as far as I know.
When you're a journalist and you're over
in Iraq or in Afghanistan,
you're in war and what you're
experiencing is so far removed from the
day to day life that most people
experience.
What,
what is it like trying to relay that to
people?
How difficult is it trying to.
Because I think so many people have this
almost a dramatic television movie slash
view of,
of war where they don't,
they don't ever experience it.
Like I would imagine probably 99 percent
of the people that are in this country
will never experience.
No.
And that's good.
You know,
it's,
I don't know that you can describe it,
uh,
in a way that will really give the full
picture of,
it's a absurdities and,
and horrors and long stretches of
boredom punctuated by terror.
Um,
and also this other piece which is taboo
to talk about,
which is the pleasure and excitement.
Then people get fighting wars.
I mean,
go.
This is Sebastian younger's thesis as
well.
I mean they just,
the comradery is the most intense
comradery they ever experienced.
And so they,
that's something they come back to
civilian life and are missing it in and
it's part of what's so difficult about
coming back
and that's why you see them there.
A lot of risk taking behavior among a
vets.
Um,
because I know that you're looking for
another way to get that hit of
adrenaline for sure.
There was a,
there was a book,
and I'm blanking on the name,
is a great book written by a much more
experienced war correspondent to me that
he used the phrase war is a drug and
that to me sums it up,
at least in my experience,
I got hooked on the experience of being
in these really elevated,
heightened situations,
cinematic dramatic situations and I
would come home and I just,
I didn't know what to do to replace it.
And so this synthetic squirt of
adrenaline that you can get from cocaine
seem to do it for me,
obviously had tremendously negative
consequences and so I wouldn't recommend
it,
but I see why people do this.
So how did you,
how did you bounce back?
That was actually the question you asked
me before that I somehow neglected to
answer.
So the doctor who pointed out that I was
an idiot and doing drugs and it caused a
panic attack.
Uh,
I agreed he didn't think I needed to go
to rehab because it was the,
it was pretty short lived.
It was.
I was in my early thirties when I
started on.
Still in my early thirties when I had a
panic attack and so it was only a couple
of years,
he said,
just have wanting to come see me once or
twice a week forever,
forever basically saying it.
He said basically indefinitely.
So I still say it,
but not,
not.
Yeah,
it's a good business model,
but not that.
I mean it's been,
well north of a,
it's been about 13 years,
so I don't see them that often now,
but for a long time I saw him
intensively so that,
you know,
it wasn't easy.
It's not easy and I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't call what I mean,
there are people who have had drug
addictions that are vastly more severe
than mine.
Um,
but it's,
it sucks to stop a habit that is giving
you pleasure on,
you know,
pretty,
pretty prominent areas of your brain
while you're
situation.
What you're talking about is very,
very,
very extreme situation.
Like being a journalist,
a war correspondent,
going over there,
experiencing that intense sort of
adrenaline rush and then having your,
your issues with it.
But it seems like there's a tremendous
amount of people today that are
stimulating themselves.
Adderall.
It was a big one.
I mean it's just A.
I know I've,
I've found out recently like four or
five people that I didn't know that were
on adderall and it seems like you just
sort of start asking questions and you
find out how many people.
I mean all these,
my kid goes to school with a bunch of
other kids and you get to meet the
parents and like fucking half of them
were on adderall.
It's very weird.
And adderall is a form of amphetamine
and it seems like,
um,
it just,
it's mind boggling how many people are
doing this stuff.
We're dosing ourselves with all sorts of
things so it can be stimulated
stimulants,
but it also can be a Benzos,
you know,
cousins of Valium.
Um,
it can be shopping,
gambling,
it can be a,
a whatever except the twitter.
Um,
and I think it,
just speaking,
we have a neuroscientist in the room,
so I'll let him say more about this.
And also a guy who's more experienced
practitioner of Buddhism that I am.
But,
but,
you know,
it does speak to the nature of the
human mind that we're always on the hunt
for the next little hit of dopamine and
now there are lots of ways to get it.
Well,
it's also very bizarre that you can just
do that.
I mean,
I don't think there's ever been a time
in history where you could just take a
pill and you'll be elevated for five or
six hours.
I mean that your doctor will give you
this pill and they'll encourage you to
take it and then you'll find out that 50
percent of the people in your community
and take it.
I've been,
I've done stories about parents who
steal it from the kids.
Also just caffeine.
I mean I'm,
you know,
I'm reaching for the coffee here,
having slept poorly last night.
But that is,
and that's just as much of a drug.
It's just not as.
It's not as potent.
The drug is taken methamphetamine or,
or,
or adderall or anything else that's a
drug drug.
But,
um,
mean as a whole,
this,
this had civilizational consequences
when,
when humanity,
more or less switched from alcohol in
the morning to caffeine in the morning,
that's just,
things got a lot different than we used
for,
for hundreds of years.
People were just drinking ale and wine
in the morning,
uh,
before,
before coffee and tea became huge in
Europe.
And,
and it,
it kind of colonialism the,
the,
the engine of colonialism to a
significant degree was coffee,
tea,
sugar,
and,
you know,
things are behavior changed.
So people that were drinking ale and
wine weren't,
wasn't a big part of it.
The reason why they drank it with food
is because the water would get stagnant.
Yeah.
Well there's the issue with clean water
too.
Yeah.
But when,
if just imagine the consequences of you
and everyone,
you know,
getting up in the morning and just
starting with beer or wine
that
long day or a very short one.
Yeah.
So,
um,
but yeah,
it's.
But the fundamental point of the
underlying neuroscience is that all of
these drugs,
anything you're putting into your body,
it is modifying the behavior of your
brain,
is only modifying the existing available
neurochemistry of your brain.
I mean the these,
these molecules either gets your brain
to secrete more of an existing
neurotransmitter or they mimic an
existing neurotransmitter binding to the
same receptor site where they keep
something in play longer than it would
otherwise have been,
that they block the uptake of of
neurotransmitters or neuromodulators.
So it's not.
You're a drug is never get in your brain
to do something.
Your brain is incapable of doing so.
And that's the most extreme thing,
like dmt or Lsd in the brain.
The brain is still doing all of that.
And so it stands to reason that there
are potentially other ways of getting
the brain to do that.
Whether it's meditation or whether it's
computer interface ultimately to the
brain.
People who are interested in in brain
computer interface that not only allows
a quadriplegic to move a robotic arm or
gets a a,
a Parkinson's patient to be able to
move.
But you know,
the,
to the ultimate degree,
I mean actually augmenting human
function that's a or opening landscapes
of mind,
psychedelic and otherwise that have been
unexplored.
I mean,
all,
all of that is
um,
in principle possible because again,
we're just talking about electro
chemical phenomenon happening in our
heads which are being,
which is just there to be
modulator.
Now when you were talking about being
depressed and Sam,
you're talking about re uptake
inhibitors,
I want to know what are your,
what are your thoughts on the massive
amount of people there are on Ssri is
now.
I mean this is another thing that I know
how many people I know that I'm either
on or have been on some sort of
antidepressants and it seems,
I mean to the layman,
to me,
to someone who's never taken them or
doesn't have personal experience with it
massively overprescribed.
Yeah.
Well anything I say is with the caveat
that this is.
I mean,
I'm not a neurologist.
I don't have.
No.
I have zero clinical experience and I'm
certainly not my area.
I'm not up on the recent literature on
the efficacy of antidepressants,
but there is clearly,
it's like anything,
there's a spectrum.
There are people who have been
unambiguously helped by antidepressants
and there are people who are on them who
shouldn't be on them,
you know,
and there are people who are on them who
wants to get off them and find it
surprisingly difficult to get off them.
And it's uh,
it's just,
it's,
these are blunt instruments by by
definition because it's anything that's
modulating serotonin in this case is
effective everywhere.
Serotonin is effective and it's just,
there's no magical property of
have a
finding the neuromodulator where,
where only the symptoms you want to
relieve our effect because these,
these,
these chemicals do a lot of things and a
lot of places and even in your gut,
right?
So it's not said that hence the side
effects you get with almost any
medication.
And we would have to get,
it would be in many respects as a matter
of luck to find a pharmacological target
that actually does just what you want it
to do.
Because it just to say that,
that those receptors are not elsewhere,
that are going to reduce side effects
for you.
So,
um,
that,
that's why a different kind of a
intervention,
something like ultimately some,
some electrical or magnetic or,
or a machine based could be more
targeted because then you're,
you're not just putting something in the
bloodstream that spreads everywhere.
Bye Bye.
Machine based.
You mean something like electrodes that
they put on the mind to or the surface
of the head to stimulate areas of the
brain.
Yeah.
And again,
what we have now is also still pretty
primitive and anything that you would
have that would be super futuristic
wouldn't seem to require that you,
you put something actually inside your
head,
right?
So whether that's a neurosurgery or I'm
putting something into the bloodstream
that somehow gets inside your head what
it is an injectable,
um,
you know.
So for instance,
Elon Musk just mentioned something
called a which he called neural lace,
which is a,
believe a term that came from a Scifi
novel.
I don't think it originates with him.
I'm not a big science fiction reader,
but he's got a,
uh,
he announced an investment in a company
called neuro neuro link,
which is looking at looking at some
advanced brain computer interface,
uh,
based on the idea that you could get a
way with the,
with these new micro electrodes,
you can get an injectable Mesh like a,
like a wire mesh that just integrates
with the brain or very likely just the
cortex.
Uh,
and I believe this work has already been
done in mice and the mice are,
you know,
have survived and are living with,
with this mesh in there in their brains.
And again,
this is not research.
I'm close to it all.
I'm in and he just announced it a couple
of weeks ago.
But,
um,
in principle,
yeah,
you're,
you're talking about having a,
whether it's a mesh or whether it's,
it's a bag neato electric particles and
it's something that is on site around
individual neurons or assemblages of
neurons which can both read out and
input wirelessly signal from those
neurons.
So just both,
you know,
putting your thoughts into the world by,
influencing effectors,
a robotic arms or cursors on screens or
whatever it is,
and also influencing your mind based on
whatever
puts you want to put in there from the
world,
whether that's Doug mentions,
hack you and yeah,
exactly.
Well that opens,
it opens all of those concerns.
You know,
the Russians,
it's always the Russians,
Chinese gambling.
I think the Chinese people are
responsible for a lot of the propaganda
that makes us think about the Russians.
Just push it off on them,
push it off on them.
Um,
I'm prepared to blame the Russians for a
lot at this point.
Blame a law.
What a slippery slope though for humans
becoming cyborgs.
I mean we're,
we're already like some weird form of
semi hot right now.
Karen,
our cell phones,
like it's a baby,
you know,
like you leave your cell phone or home
like,
oh my God,
I forgot the baby.
I mean it's a very strange thing that we
already have and there's not a whole lot
of steps between that and snapchat
glasses.
Jamie's got the snapchat glasses and
seeing those things I didn't know they
existed.
The other very strange they are.
They have little cameras on them and now
you to go ahead,
throw them on.
So.
But now he knows how to use them.
Google glass just was totally still born
right?
I mean I didn't.
Yeah,
it didn't work.
So He's,
he's,
he's transmitting or he's making a video
right now with that left side.
See how the left side of spinning with
snapchat do like 15 seconds,
10 seconds at 10.
A little counter.
It's just flashing.
Was like the last three seconds and you
can hit it again and do another 20
seconds so you can hold it and do like
30 seconds or something like that.
Yeah.
Step one.
Is that spinning just to alert the
people you're looking at that
to sort of alert me to,
to let me know that my recording is
done.
Probably a little bit to let you know
too,
but that's probably the only
notification.
You know that I'm recording and it just
posts.
It doesn't post automatically and now I
have to link it to my phone and then
post it from there.
Okay.
The Google glass thing made people very
uncomfortable.
I mean I,
I tried to very early prototype.
I have a good friend of mine who was a
executive at Google at the time and she
got ahold of one of the really early
ones that actually had to be tethered by
a cord and you know,
you talk to it and swipe it and I played
with it a couple of times and we used it
once at a ufc way in where I put it on
and I broadcast from the way and it's
very,
very odd.
But it made people made people very
uncomfortable.
Like you could see the difference when
they saw you with that thing on all of a
sudden there was all this apprehension.
They're being recorded,
are transmitted or.
But how long?
How long do we have where we're still
people?
Well,
how long before you asked that question?
Our sense of private.
I remember,
I remember what it was like to be
neurotic about the sound of your voice
on a voicemail or Laura on the answering
machine,
right?
Like rerecording the outgoing message
and,
and just just being worried about your
voice showing up and someone else's
tape.
Right.
And now we were living in this pan optic
on surveillance society where you just
assume you're on camera virtually every
moment or in public,
although I guess people don't think
about it all that much.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think we're the norms around
privacy shift just because we get so
much value from having the data
ultimately
I guess,
but it just seems also like to just this
inexorable pole towards this connection
we're going to have it.
It just seems like if you just,
if you take where we are now and sort of
look at all the data points and
extrapolate,
it doesn't look good,
it just salt,
but it's both.
It's both bad and good.
The fake news thing is horrible,
but the ability to fact check in,
to be able to pick up your phone and
find out what's true is has also never
been better,
so it's like we're both vulnerable in a
way that we've never been and where
we're empowered
in a way that we've always been true,
but technological progress.
Yeah.
It just seems like there's a certain
amount of time we have left before we
give birth to some new thing we're
talking about just integrating ourselves
biologically with,
with our machines and also something
that's independent of us,
some artificial intelligence independent
of us.
You want,
you want to look for some fear around
that.
You got the right guy,
right?
Yeah.
Well we've talked about Evan's past
those fears here.
Yeah.
I mean Josh has apps freaked me out this
morning,
sent me some articles about the self
driving trucks that are already going in
Australia that are as big as a seven 67
and they're driving down the road by
themselves with cargo,
probably nuclear waste or something.
You know,
just to wind down the road,
but people are so bad at it.
Driving that,
yeah,
the robots just have to get reliably
better than people and then you'll just
feel nothing but relief.
They probably already are yet.
Well,
yeah,
I mean they're.
I think they probably are,
as far as I know from what I hear from
Tesla that yeah,
the,
the accident,
the man hours,
they have people using the autopilot in
the autopilots not at all.
Perfect.
Obviously two people have died already
from,
from using it badly,
but still they have something like some
millions of man hours.
You have autopilot assisted driving and
I think that is has been safer than just
pure ape.
Did you see the video of the guy who
fell asleep in traffic in San Francisco?
He's literally out cold and his car is
driving on the highway kind of fit.
I mean he's just some guy on his way to
work,
just pass out completely mouth open and
people are filming them.
His cars driving down the road and
actually probably the people filming him
or doing the.
The more dangerous thing.
You're right.
Yeah.
Well texting and driving drive me crazy
to see it.
Like to be in an uber now you can look
around,
you can see how many people are texting.
Yeah.
Including your driver sometimes.
That drives me crazy.
I.
Here's the guy that dude's Alcoa is cars
creeping along and stop and go traffic
and he is completely alcohol.
Wow.
Well it works.
The autopilot works.
Yeah.
No,
it does work.
Yeah.
Texting and driving scares the shit out
of me.
That pokemon go thing.
Thank God that that died off but
stopped.
I was driving on the highway and there
was a woman to the left of us and I
noticed that she was being,
her face was illuminated by her cell
phone.
So I look over and she's playing pokemon
as she's driving.
So I guess I don't know how pokemon
works,
but I guess you pick up things and as
you're driving you get stuff.
And so she was playing the game while
she was on the hot,
barely paying attention to the road.
Looking at her phone.
This is the argument for,
for robot drivers.
Yeah.
And also it will open up and when you
are ultimately being driven safely,
buy a car that you trust more than you
trust yourself.
Then just imagine the,
the,
the information consumption,
entertainment options that open up
there.
You'll watch movies,
you'll,
you'll listen to podcasts,
you'll get work done and it will become
a space of more not,
we're not gonna miss having to pay
attention to the road.
You know,
maybe maybe there's some people want to
drive recreationally for some reason,
but um,
it's,
it will just be a new space where you
won't believe that 40,000
people every year were dying because we
couldn't figure out how to drive safely.
But isn't that a slippery slope like
$40,000?
Well that's a great thing that 40,000
people are not going to die.
But the idea that we're going gonna stop
people from driving a car,
you're gonna have to live with these
40,000
people.
That's not what I was going to say,
but I was gonna say,
I mean pretty much all the things that
people do.
And then it's going to get down to why
have people mean ultimately that's the.
When I look at the event horizon of
artificial intelligence,
it's why,
why would we were so far?
We're not going to get our shit together
by the time artificial intelligence is
given birth to.
While that that all goes to what we
build,
we build artificial intelligence that is
independent of us and seems conscious
and is more powerful than us.
Well then we are.
We have built a in limit.
We have essentially built a god that we
now have to be in relationship to and
hopefully that works out well for us.
And it's very easy to see how it might
not.
I think they're even scarier cases in
that that we could build something that
has like power,
but there's no reason.
I think it's conscious.
It's just,
it's just,
it's no more conscious than our current
computers,
which is to say that intelligence and
consciousness may be separable
phenomenon that you could.
Intelligence can scale,
but consciousness need not come along
for the ride.
And that for me is the worst case
scenario because we inherit all of the
danger of,
of,
of this,
the power of this system being
misaligned with our interest.
We could build something that is godlike
in its power.
And yet,
uh,
we,
we could essentially be canceling the
prospects of the evolution of
consciousness because of this thing
wipes us out that,
you know,
I think it's,
I'm Nick Bostrom,
the philosopher who wrote a great book
on this entitled Superintelligence,
I think he calls this the Disneyland
without children and were like,
well,
basically we could build this,
this incredibly powerful,
intelligent landscape that continues to
refine itself and its own powers.
Uh,
who knows what ways,
my ways perhaps that are,
that are unimaginable to us.
And yet they're,
the lights aren't on.
You know,
there's,
there's nothing that is like to be this
machine or system of machines is in the
way that is probably nothing that has to
be the internet right now.
You think of all this going on,
on the Internet.
I,
you know,
I don't think the Internet is conscious
of any of it right now.
The question is could the internet
become conscious of what its thinking
and um,
I think there's no reason to think it
couldn't,
it's just we don't understand the,
the physical basis of consciousness,
yet the real question is why would it do
anything?
I mean if it doesn't have any of the
biological motivations that people have
to breed and to stay alive and to,
you know,
fight or flight and to be nervous and
this desire to carry on our genes mean
if you really did build the ultimate
supercomputer artificial intelligence
that was beyond our capacity for reason
and understanding what niches do.
Nothing because everything is pointless.
Well,
no,
because what we would do,
we would program it,
it would do whatever we asked it to do
initially,
right?
We things we program now have goals,
Your,
your thermostat is trying to regulate
the temperature in the room.
Um,
and when get,
when it gets too warm,
it kicks on the air and it,
when it gets too cold,
it kicks on the heat.
And I mean,
that's just it.
That's a goal,
right?
And um,
so we would,
we are everything we build.
That's automated,
has goals explicitly programmed into it,
and when you're talking about a truly
intelligent machine,
it will have,
it will discover a goals that you have
never programmed into it,
that are our intermediate to the goal
that you have programs.
So if,
if the goal of this machine is to pick
up all the trash in this room and you
physically try to stop it,
well then it's gonna try to get around
you to pick up the rest of the trash and
the room.
Right?
So it's,
it's,
you know,
this probably already true of a Roomba,
right?
I actually don't have a room,
but,
but if you,
if you put something in the way of the
room,
but it's going to get around the thing
you have put in it's way so that it can
get to the rest of the room.
So that's an intermediate goal.
And some of these goals need never have
been explicitly thought about or
represented,
which is to say programmed into it.
And yet they,
they're,
they're formed by,
by the fact that the thing has a
longterm goal.
And one of the,
one of the concerns is that we could
build something that has a longterm
goal,
build something that's super powerful,
that has a longterm goal,
which in principle is benign,
right?
As executive,
this is something we want,
and yet it could discover instrumental
goals that are deeply hostile to what we
want.
I mean,
the thing doesn't have common sense,
right?
We haven't figured out how to build
common sense into the machine so that
the cartoon examples of this kind of
thing.
But one example that Ilan used when he
first was expressing fears about this,
if you built a machine,
the only goal of which was was to cancel
spam,
right?
No more.
We don't want it.
What we want.
No more spam.
Get rid of the spam.
Well,
an easy way to get rid of spam is just
killed all the people right now.
That's a crazy thing to think,
but it's not in unless you've built,
unless you've closed the door to that
intermediate goal,
there's no reason to think that a
for powerful machine couldn't form such
a goal.
My question would be,
if this super powerful machine has the
ability to create new super powerful
machines,
wouldn't use the same mandate,
would it,
would it still try to follow the
original programming or would it realize
that our original program is only
instrumental to the success of the human
race and it might think the human race
is ridiculous and preposterous and why?
Why not just program something that it
thinks is the ultimate intelligence?
Something beyond our capacity for
reasoning and understanding now and that
thing.
I would wonder in the absence of any
sort of biological motivations and the
absence would mean.
Do you think of all the things that we
do,
I mean you,
you break it down to what motivates
people to get out of bed.
What motivates people to do good,
but my sense of community,
a desire to breed the social status,
all these different things that motivate
people to do things.
We remove all of those.
And what actions would it take?
Well,
I think,
I think you want to build it in a way
that is focused on our wellbeing.
And so for instance,
I had Stuart Russell on my podcast,
he's a computer scientist at Berkeley
who,
um,
unlike many computer scientists takes
this problem really seriously and has a
thought a lot about it.
And in his lab,
I believe they're working on a,
a way of thinking about safety that is,
that is open ended and flexible without,
without pretending we have any of the
right answers in the near term or,
or likely to have them.
So you want to build a system that wants
to know what you want,
right at each point.
Like,
so that's tracking what humanity one
wants in terms of its goals and wants to
stay aligned with whatever it is we
want,
um,
wants to,
wants to learn from what we seem to want
based on our behavior.
But,
um,
and so there could be some kind of
clarifying function.
Where were we,
you know,
we can get our priorities more aligned
in dialogue with the super intelligent
machine.
But the bottom line is it always wants
to do it.
It doesn't think it knows what we want
and it continually wants to keep
approximating better and better what we
want.
And so from my point of view,
the most crucial thing is you,
you always want the door to remain open
to the statement.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
That's not what I wanted.
Right?
Like you wouldn't want to be in the
presence of this.
God likes super power that will always
take direction from you when say,
wait,
that's
not going in the right direction and
this.
So the fear is we could build something
that is,
is just not amenable to being controlled
in that way.
Is it not the case that computer
scientists are starting to come around
to the idea that there's real danger,
a,
potentially there's dangerous potential
in,
in Ai.
I mean,
I was listening to when you talked to
will macaskill a few weeks ago who was
saying,
you know,
we,
it was,
it was just a few years from starting to
think about how to split the atom to
actually having a bomb.
Um,
are they not coming around the idea that
these,
that technology can progress much faster
than we think of?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's a whole spectrum of the people who
think that this is never going to happen
or it's so far away that thinking about
it now is completely irrational to
people who are super worried and think
that huge changes are imminent.
And so it's just the spectrum.
I'm with the ladder.
Yeah.
No,
it's as am I,
what my concern is not even with the
initial construction,
like the initial ai,
my concern is with what the ai creates.
If we give the AI ability to improve
upon itself and look at are irrational
thoughts and how we've programmed itself
to support the human race.
And then it might go,
well,
why the fuck would I do that?
Like you guys are ridiculous.
Like,
oh,
this is a new life form.
This is a new.
We've given birth to some incredibly
potent new thing that we think of it as
artificial by.
I mean,
is it really,
it's just a form of life.
It's a form of life that we've created.
Human beings have sort of,
the analogy I always use is that we're
some sort of an electronic caterpillar
giving birth to some spectacular
butterfly we're not even aware of while
we're building our cocoon.
We're just doing it.
I mean there's a caterpillar fully
conscious of what it's doing when it
makes that cocoon,
probably not,
but it just does and there's plenty of
examples of that in nature of something
that's doing something that's going
through some metamorphosis that's
completely unconscious.
My worry would be.
I guess it's not even really a worry.
It's more like looking at the
possibility of the AI improving upon
itself and making a far better version
than we could create like almost
instantaneously.
Right?
Isn't that if you give it the ability to
be autonomous and you give it the
ability to innovate and to try to figure
out what's a better way around things
and what's a better way to program
things and then make its own version of
what it is.
It's going to be spectacular.
I mean it really will be just.
I mean it's obviously just talking shit,
but really would be a god.
I mean,
you're talking about something that if
we give it the ability to create,
we give it the ability to think,
reason,
rationalize,
and then build,
build something better.
I mean by bill,
you should be thinking more software
than hardware to make it there.
There's obviously there's anything is
possible.
Anything that can be built with
intelligence can be built with
intelligence,
so you could be talking about armies of
robots and nanotechnology and everything
else.
That's.
That is the staple
of the PSI Phi scare scenario,
but I'm more likely and certainly faster
and ultimately more powerful.
You're talking about something that can
rewrite it's own code,
improve.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's the code that is that is dictating
the intelligence and so you're talking
about something that could be for the
longest time,
invisible and just happening on the
Internet,
right?
You're talking about code that could,
could be put into financial markets,
right?
Which could be built to be self
modifying.
Right,
and then it's already out in the wild.
It's not.
It's not sequestered in some air gapped
computer in a lab.
It's out there and it's changing itself.
Now.
That would be totally irresponsible
thing to do from a,
from a,
uh,
a software designers point of view,
I think at this point,
but um,
there's just no question that we're
going to get to a place where I'm going.
It's either,
either it will be the province of one
lab that gets there first or it will be
open source,
but you're talking about software rev,
US figuring out how to write better.
It's better software which becomes the
basis of general intelligence and then
where that gets put and what gets done
with that.
That's,
that's the question isn't in the real
question of also the race to see who can
come up with one first.
I mean once,
once the idea gets put out there,
like the idea of the nuclear bomb.
I mean obviously no one in their right
mind thinks it's a good idea to make a
nuclear bomb.
What that story is.
Especially a sobering because I may
forget the,
the details.
I think it was.
I couldn't,
I could have this backwards.
I think it was Rutherford,
the two famous physicists involve to
Rutherford who said we're never going to
unlock the,
the,
um,
I think,
yeah,
I think it was Rutherford gave a talk
saying that we're never going to unlock
the energy that we now know to be in the
Adam and Leo Szilard the next day
produced the,
the,
uh,
the equations that I'm locked in the
next,
next and an indirect response to this
announcement.
Like,
okay,
let's just wait.
That's bullshit.
And they gave him the next morning,
woke up and produce that.
They produced the math that gave us the,
the atomic bomb.
So it's,
it can happen really fast and if you
want to get those details exactly right.
Listen to what's Stuart Russell said on
my podcast.
Well,
oppenheimer in like a really ironic
twist wasn't a Buddhist.
He.
No,
he was a fan of,
of um,
Hinduism.
Technically.
I mean he was,
he taught himself Sanskrit apparently in
three months.
One never how much this is exaggerated,
but his,
his publicists will tell you that he
taught himself Sanskrit in three months
to read the Bhagavad Gita,
which is the one of the texts of,
of Hinduism,
the quote that he gave out as the first
bomb was tested.
I've become death,
death destroyer of worlds.
And then when you hear him saying it's
even more creepy because you could see
the sort of remorse.
And so have you seen it?
No.
I also get the photo.
Every photo of Oppenheimer.
He looks,
he just looks haunted.
Well,
he was hanging out with weird to see him
with his general.
I was watching some documentary on the
creation of the atom bomb and he was,
uh,
you know,
it's hanging out with these generals as
they're probably Curtis Lemay.
Yeah.
And you see the two of them together and
you're like,
what a bizarre pairing.
Like this one monkey needs this other
genius to make this bomb so he can drop
it on these people.
And the guy realizes that if he doesn't
make it,
someone's going to make it and it could
be dropped on them.
And that's,
that's the thing we are,
we were genuinely in a race condition
there and we,
and we didn't know how close the Nazis
were.
It turns out that they weren't as close
as we feared.
But yeah,
just imagine Hitler haven't gotten there
first.
Right.
With the help of Heisenberg and others
play at Jamie
scripture,
the game test persuade to pressed him
takes on form.
Now I ended up coming to worlds.
He does not look like a happy dude.
What a,
what a burden.
But it's actually,
I read the history of that,
that effort,
the Manhattan project and the Trinity
Test.
It is super sobering because there was,
they move forward in,
in a context of real uncertainty about
what was going to happen.
I mean there were they,
in terms of the yield of the first bomb,
there was a,
a range,
I think of a,
a hundred fold difference of opinion of
what they were going to get.
This thing went off.
Um,
and there were some people who still
placed some possibility a on the
prospect of igniting the atmosphere.
Yeah.
And just canceling all of life right
now,
they had,
they had spent a lot of time to,
I mean,
they did something like due diligence
where they were,
many of them were confident it wouldn't,
but that was not without,
beyond the realm of possibility for some
of the people working on it.
And um,
so we,
we have shown a propensity for taking
possibly existential risks to develop
new technology because there's,
there's a reason to develop it.
And in this case,
the destruct,
the destructive potential is so obvious
because it's all destructive potential.
I mean,
we're,
we're building the biggest bombs we
possibly can build.
And so it,
it's just,
it's not difficult to think about the
danger.
It's all danger,
right?
Um,
and these bombs,
you know,
now getting into the hands of the wrong
people with Ai,
it's so seductive because if you looked
at it,
looked at in,
in,
in one light,
it's just all upside and there's nothing
better than intelligence is nothing more
intrinsically desirable than
intelligence.
And so to get more of it is,
seems an intrinsic good.
And so it takes an extra step to say,
well,
wait a minute,
this could in fact be the most dangerous
thing we've ever done.
And you have to,
you have to.
You have to spend a lot of time fighting
that,
that ideological battle with people who
just think,
no,
just this is just all upside.
This is what could be.
What could go wrong.
You're just,
you're just scare mongering and the year
just evil that you've seen too many
terminator movies.
Is that even possible to.
No,
not.
Not with the first.
The first was good.
First one.
Second was good.
There's one in there that I don't think
I've seen all of the three or four.
I don't know.
Like I think it was.
I think I lost touch after the second
I've seen.
I haven't seen any more than two.
I,
I dunno,
I just,
I feel like it's been because of the
race because the idea that there's a
race to get to it,
it seems like it's inevitable that
someone actually does create it and much
like the atomic bomb,
it'll probably launched,
probably be launched without a true
understanding of what his potential is.
That's my fear.
I'm terrified of it.
I think about it all the time.
I,
I stepped back sometimes and I look at
like the city of Los Angeles,
of the skyline.
All the lights go off and I'm like,
this,
this is all new.
Like this has only been here for a few
hundred years like this,
this,
there was nothing here.
1,700,
there was nothing.
This is nothing.
Now look at it,
it's all lit up and there's a gigantic
grid you see from the sky,
like what are we looking at 300 years
from now?
Like what?
What are we looking at with all these
things that were feverously attempting
to build and create.
Yeah.
Well the,
our dependence on the net is sobering.
I mean,
just what you just forget about all of
these highfalutin fears of,
of roguey.
I just,
just,
we don't have a backup for the Internet
and the Internet goes down.
What happens in the real world a lot.
That is,
that is very difficult to recover from.
You know,
what happens to your money,
right?
I mean,
what is money when there is no right or,
or just just imagine some malicious code
just destroying the record of,
of uh,
money,
you know,
just to getting into the banking system,
right?
So it's like you,
you have men have to go look for the
paperwork you may or may not have in
your desk to argue that you have a
certain amount of money because you
know,
all those bits got scrambled,
right?
Um,
and we need some,
all of this is just this,
there's so many aspects of this,
but the fact that you can now credibly
fake audio,
right?
So someone can listen to sample,
you know,
five minutes of this podcast and then
produce a conversation.
We've never had invoices exactly like
our own.
And those edits will no longer be
discernible.
I mean,
we're basically there now and we're
almost there with video,
right where you could just have our
mouths moving in the correct way.
So I go to snapchat these crazy snapchat
filters.
I don't know if you know about these,
but my daughter did pull up the one of
my daughter being Abraham Lincoln.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
I mean it's really rudimentary right
now,
but my six year old loves it.
She thinks it's hilarious and she
constantly uses it all the time.
Like she just like,
can I pay with your phone?
And she grabs my phone and then she
starts doing these little videos like
somehow or another,
their little brains like sync up
immediately with the technology.
Whereas if I gave it to my mom,
she's be like,
I don't even know what this is.
What do I do?
That six year old could figure it out
like that.
Check this out.
I lost my tooth
if I showed that,
if I showed this to my daughters,
you just never hear from them again.
It would be the most captivating thing.
I mean,
this is obviously black and white and
she's being silly and it's really
obvious.
Obviously it's fake,
but man,
how far.
I mean this is thing in the world who
looks like Abraham linking.
It's mimicking the voice.
You can't,
like you see her,
her mouth.
You can't discern where her mouth ends
and Abraham Lincoln's face begins.
But here.
But what's so insidious about this
technology I'm talking about now is that
someone can fake.
I mean it's basically what is already
true of Photoshop,
right?
Where you can't tell.
You have to be an expert to tell whether
the person was standing next to Donald
Trump at the time because they could
have just been put there,
but with expert and expert use of
Photoshop.
But now we're talking about being able
to produce content where you are saying
the thing that completely destroys your
reputation,
but it's pure.
It's just fake news is just fiction.
And so we need.
I mean,
I don't know what the fix where this is
a,
you know,
I've just Spec,
and this is again something I know very
little about,
but I've clearly something like the
blockchain has to be a way of anchoring
each piece of digital content so that
there's like a chain of custody where
you see exactly where this came from in
a way that's not favorable.
And so if I take,
you know,
your podcast and example,
if someone is producing a clip that
purports to be from your podcast where
you're saying something insane,
um,
that just has to be a clear fingerprint
digitally,
which shows whether that came from you
and Jamie or whether this came from some
Macedonian hacker who just decided to
screw with you.
Yeah.
Well there's not.
No,
no,
I know,
but that clearly we need that.
We need that tomorrow because the
technology is here to produce totally
fake content,
which is.
I am worried about that.
I'm also worried about the idea that
someone anywhere is completely in charge
and knows what's going on.
You know,
I always point to you remember that guy
that went onstage with Obama and
pretended to be a sign language
translator,
that one that was really that this guy
was South Africa or something like that.
I believe it was,
was it?
That sounds right.
But I forget where it was.
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I mean that was amazing because it's
just so few people read sign language
that wasn't it around a Mandela.
I don't know.
I don't remember the details,
but I remember thinking this fucking guy
is three feet away from the president
who was three feet away from the
president and you would think that they
had vetted everyone out.
So here's this guy talking and that guy
is just completely making things up.
He has no idea,
has no idea how to do sign language and
that,
you know,
that can happen.
There was another incidence where a guy
had gotten in an elevator with Obama,
a security guard here with a gun,
with a gun loaded gun in an elevator
with Obama.
Nobody's screened them.
It's just people aren't really on the
ball.
You know,
there was a bit for my last comedy
special about the uh,
guy that broke into the White House,
but there was a woman guarding the front
door by herself and they had shut the
alarm off because it kept going off,
so they had a fuck up,
just shut it off.
And then there was a guy who was on the
lawn who's supposed to be,
he had canines,
supposed to be guarding lawn.
He took his earpiece out to talk to his
girlfriend on the cell phone.
He had a backup,
a walkie talkie because they have a
backup one,
but he left that in his locker.
So it was like all these steps and this
guy just hit the perfect sweet spot
where you hopped the fence,
ran the whatever,
100 yards plus to get to the White
House,
got to the door.
It was unlocked,
got through it.
There was a girl by herself through her
to the ground and just ran through the
White House and was in there for five,
10 minutes.
He had a knife,
the knife.
He
was basically trying to.
He was basically a suicide by cop
situation because they hadn't caught
him.
This is what's really hilarious when
people think that the government is
watching out for you.
They weren't even watching this guy and
listen to what this guy did.
He got arrested.
They pulled him over,
I believe it was less than three months
before that with 800 rounds of
ammunition.
He had two rifles,
a shot gun and the ax and a machete and
a map of Washington with a fucking x
where the White House is and they let
them go.
They have.
There has to be a crime there,
but they weren't even watching that guy.
Like the idea that they're watching you,
but we're not built as a species for
perfect vigilance.
That's so not perfect.
I mean,
that's so ridiculous.
Thinking about even the Tsa,
you know,
we,
it's just,
we're just,
we're just not built for that.
Twitter and twitter can confound even
the perfect vigilance,
but just look what happened at the
Oscars.
That was just their only job is to get
those envelopes right.
You've got two people with briefcases
and one guy starts tweeting and produces
the wrong envelope.
I mean,
it's just.
Is that what happened?
He was tweeting.
Yeah,
he was tweeting.
This is brutal,
but he took a photo of.
I forget what actress,
but it clearly he was.
I mean they have been deleted the photo,
but people recovered it.
Yeah,
he.
He took a shot of somebody I don't
charlise their own or somebody who was
walking backstage and put it on his
twitter feed and then that.
Then the very next moment was the moment
when he had to hand over the right
envelope and he just handed over the
envelope for the best bankers,
but that's been their only job is to get
this straight,
just safeguarding the envelopes so it's
all adorable.
Yeah,
there's some.
There's something I really enjoy about
the folly of people that.
That's one of the main things that I
worry about with ai that are the things
that we find cute about us being
ridiculous like that or like the sign
language guy or any of these things,
but that.
But that's the thing that computers are
really good at it.
I mean one is computer to get good at
this sort of thing,
but we're programming them right now.
But we,
we can,
we can program them to,
to fill in the gaps for stupid.
We want.
What we want to do is automate
repetitive behavior and error detection
that we know we're not good at the
moment.
You have a,
a TSA screening robot that,
that doesn't get distracted.
I mean these machines don't get
distracted,
right?
They don't,
they don't get hungry.
They don't have to take bathroom breaks,
they don't,
they're not looking at the person who's
looking at them and get captivated by
some social glitch.
Right?
So that it all,
if you have a bomb screening robot,
that's all it will do and it will be
better once it,
you know,
whatever.
Whatever they visual signature or of a,
of a bomb is when you're talking about
looking for one in a bag.
Once computers get better at that than
people they will be.
They will be reliable in a way that
people can never be.
And then we know that about ourselves,
so that's we want to,
we want to outsource all of that stuff
is driving is the perfect example,
you know,
you don't,
you don't have self driving cars that
are falling asleep or you know,
will reading billboards and while
they're driving at 80 miles an hour and
um,
and so we want that and,
and,
but the scary scary stuff is when it can
change itself,
that that's a principle that will allow
it to kind of escape from our control or
we just,
we build something where we haven't
anticipated the consequences and,
and the incentives are wrong.
The incentive,
the incentives are not aligned to make
us prudent in the development of that
and what an arms race is.
The worst case for that because with the
incentives are to get to the end zone as
quickly as you can because the guy next
to you is doing the same and you don't
know how you don't know whether he's
ahead of you or behind you.
Right?
And,
and it's a winner take all scenario
because the amount of wealth that will
go to the winner of this race,
if things work,
if,
if this person that doesn't know,
if this group doesn't destroy the world
is unimaginable.
I mean,
it's just,
we're talking about a level of,
of um,
kind of windfall profits that we just
haven't seen in any other domain.
Well,
perfect example is the creation of the
atomic bomb.
I mean,
look at 70 years from the creation of
the atomic bomb to today,
which is literally a blip in human
history.
Just a tiny little blink of an eye.
And then the United States emerges as
the greatest superpower of the world's
ever known.
And that's going to be directly
attributed to those bombs that were
dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Mean that from there on,
that's where everything takes off.
When you look at human history,
if you look at us from a thousand years
from now,
it's very likely that they look at that
moment and then they go,
this is the emergence of the American
empire.
But this is so much bigger than that
because.
Because the bombs,
the power and the bomb was just,
just the,
the implicit threat that you might use
them if you get pissed off.
Right?
But you can't do anything with the bombs
here.
We're talking about the resource that
does everything.
We're talking about intelligence.
We're talking about.
We're talking about the cure for cancer.
We're talking about the best virtual
reality entertainment we're talking
about.
Uh,
that the,
everything,
everything that a human being,
once you,
you're talking about general human
intelligence and beyond,
you're talking about now having access
to suddenly having access to the
smartest people who have ever lived,
who never sleep,
who never get tired,
who never get distracted because now
their machines and the smartest people
who have never lived,
right?
People who are a thousand times smarter
than those people and getting smarter
every hour,
right?
And what are they going to do for you
when they're your slaves,
right?
Because now you're talking about because
you don't have to feed these people.
These are working for you.
Just how powerful would you suddenly be
if you had 10,000
of the smartest people in the world
working for you full time.
They don't have to be fed,
they never get disgruntled,
they don't need contracts and they just
want to do whatever Joe Rogan wants to
do and get done and you just,
you flip a switch and that's your
company,
right?
Um,
that's some version of that going to
happen.
The question is,
is it going to happen in a way that
where we get this massive dislocation
and in wealth inequality where all of a
sudden someone's got a company and
products and a business model which
obviates,
you know,
30 percent of the American workforce in
over the span of three months,
or you have some,
some political and,
and,
and economic and ethical context in
which we start sharing the wealth with
everyone.
And this,
this is again,
this is the best case scenario.
This is when we don't destroy ourselves
inadvertently by,
by producing something that's hostile to
our interests.
Daniel terrified.
Yeah,
no,
this is.
This is what hanging out with Sam does.
Just listen.
You spot.
We get to a high spot,
we get a pitcher of Margaritas and we
just watched this whole thing.
We're not gonna make it anyway.
None of this room was going to live
forever when I hang out with Sam,
usually his wife's there.
So it's like with the conversation is a
little less elliptic.
Yeah.
Well she keeps me grounded.
She is actually awesome because when
she's there she's like,
just tooling on him and um,
he giggles and stuff like that.
It's like a completely different Sam
than the guy who's under it,
like being an undertaker here and
telling you about how we're all going to
die from Ai.
Yeah.
She's,
she keeps me honest.
But um,
I mean the truth is it's not.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm cautiously.
Whoa.
This is,
there's no way to stop.
I mean,
there's no,
there's no brake to pull.
Right.
So it's like,
this is the inevitability you were
describing before.
We're moving toward this thing because
intelligence is the best thing in the
world.
I mean,
intelligence is the thing that allows us
to solve every problem we have or don't
know we have.
When we discovered what continually
discovering new problems and the
question is,
what are we going to do?
There's some global pandemic arrives and
the challenges,
do you find a vaccine for this thing or
not?
Right.
Only intelligence solves that problem
for us.
We either,
we either have the data and we can
interpret it.
We have to get that.
We have to design the experiments to get
the data.
Um,
and it's.
So,
it's,
there's no question of us deciding while
we've got.
We're just going to stick with the
intelligence we've got.
I mean,
we're just,
we're not going to do that.
We can't,
we can,
if there's other people that are working
on it,
it's exactly right because that's just
too much power.
Even if even if we decided that as an
American policy,
you know,
we were not going to let China and North
Korea and Singapore and Iran and Israel
and all these other countries do it for
us,
so I'm fine,
but right above denver,
big bucket of Margarita or,
or,
or the meditation that has helped a,
that's,
that definitely will help you.
While human beings are a real thing.
Yes.
Although I wonder if you know,
the getting enough people meditating
might improve the quality of whatever
gets created in the Ai community.
In other words,
if you have people who are a little bit
more sane as a consequence of meditation
than maybe a,
the people designing these products that
the rather these,
uh,
don't know if products the right word,
this stuff that somehow this stuff is
better.
Well,
I think it's especially relevant for the
other side of that which is when you
mean in the near term,
we clearly have a,
an employment problem.
I mean there,
there are jobs that will go away that
are not coming back and this is a
perennial problem where people need to
find meaning in life.
But,
but we've always had,
it hasn't been such a pressing problem
for thousands of years because there's
always been so much to do just to
survive.
Right now what we're.
In the ideal case,
we'll get to a place where there's
actually much less that has to be done
because we have machines that do it and
we have to.
We have seen the wisdom of mitigating
wealth inequality to some extent
bilevel were so every,
so all,
all boats
begin to rise with this tied to some
degree,
uh,
so whether it's universal basic income
or some.
So we have some mechanism to spread the
wealth around.
But then there's the
question of what do you do with your
life?
So what do you think people will do
that,
that's the easiest one is not,
but it's not so easy because people
will.
People are confused.
People in St Louis need to get their
shit together.
I mean that,
that's giving someone free time,
but find a hobby man.
I mean there's a lot of stuff to do.
If you told me that I never had to work
again,
that we just have to find things to do
all day and all my food and everything
would be taken care of.
That would be the easiest choice I've
ever made in my life.
I would just pursue things.
I would just learn how to speak a
language.
I've learned how to play an instrument.
I'd practice archery more.
I do Jujitsu more.
I don't.
That seems to me,
so riddick,
that seems to me that can be solved
really easy was a guy,
but
I think that the.
I'm not convinced I feel that I could
fill endless swaths of of free time with
a number of things that I'm interested
in including but not limited to
meditation or just hanging out with my
two year old.
However,
I'm not sure that the vast majority of
humans are like that
guidance.
That seems to be the be the easiest
thing to solve that.
Just let them know it.
Go find something fun to do.
Can start running up hills,
man,
go up,
take up Frisbee Golf.
Just to shift to do.
There's a lot of shit to do.
My concern is that more and more it
will.
It will take the form of being merely
entertained,
so we'll plug into some vr.
Last scene of wally.
I never saw that movie.
Well,
okay guys,
you should maybe pull it,
pull this up,
but the.
They're in wally.
That's a dystopian future where
everybody's riding around in those
little jazzy.
I'm a mobile wheelchairs that people
sit,
sit in Disneyland and they are also
there.
They've got huge buckets of soda and
like Turkey legs and and draped like
kind of hooked over the back of the,
of their motorized vehicle as a monitor
at the front,
which is entertaining them.
It was just obese and entertained and
immobile or mobile,
but not actually ambulatory
is Disneyland.
What were.
What's happened in our lifetime that the
smartphone has made it virtually
impossible to be bored.
Boredom used to be a thing like you'd.
You'd be sitting in the waiting room of
a doctor,
right?
And they have crappy magazines and then
you're just sitting there.
So at the end,
if you didn't know how to meditate,
you had to confront this sense of on
board right now,
a while you just go.
One thing you discovered when he learned
how to meditate is boredom is just an
inability to pay attention to anything
and you can pay attention.
Once you learn to pay attention to
anything,
even something as seemingly boring as
your breath,
it suddenly becomes incredibly
interesting.
So,
so focused attention is intrinsically
pleasurable,
but boredom is the state of,
of kind of scattered attention looking
for something that's worth paying
attention to.
And yet now with technology,
you're never going to be bored again.
And I've got,
I have at least 10 years worth of
reading on my phone,
right?
So it's like if I'm standing in live,
I,
I'm constantly pulling this thing out as
a bad thing.
Well,
it's,
it's potentially a bad thing because you
for images to take this example of,
of one interesting insight you get when
you learn to meditate.
It's incredibly powerful to cut through
the illusion of boredom.
I mean,
to realize that boredom is,
is not,
is not something you can become
interested in the feeling of boredom and
the moment you do it bites its own tail
and disappeared.
I mean it's just like a,
it's there no such thing as boredom when
you're paying close attention
to your experience.
I think the bad thing about the hyper
stimulation that we get through our
phone and,
and all of technology is that we have
lost the ability to just sit back and,
uh,
for lack of a less cliched term,
B and w we're just constantly stimulated
and that means we have trouble paying
attention when we're holding our kid in
our lap and reading him or her a book or
we find ourselves without our technology
for a moment.
There was a recent study that asked
people a,
would you rather be alone with your
thoughts or get electric shocks and a
lot of people took the electric shocks
and I actually think that is a
fundamental problem,
uh,
in terms of not being able to get in
touch with the Ra and kind of powerful,
although obvious fact that you're alive
and that you exist.
Right?
But
don't you think those people are idiots?
I mean,
you don't want electric shock.
You don't want.
I won't take an electric shock.
You're not going to take an electric
shock.
We were talking about the dude with the
snapchat.
Jamie is on the ball.
I don't want those glasses either,
but you know what I'm saying.
He doesn't use the glasses.
He just explores it because it's
fascinating.
But you know what I'm talking about.
I mean,
we're not talking about rational people.
We're talking about lowest common
denominator.
People that would take an electric
shock,
you would take an electric shock
study of they're not just picking idiot
are they asking and what?
How are they phrasing the question,
but it also doesn't.
I have
to be conscious.
So for instance,
we,
we willingly grant our attention to
things which retrospectively we can
judge produce more or less nothing but
pain for us.
So I was like,
well,
I mean I'm continually thinking about
this and rethinking about this with
respect to social media.
Like I.
So when I like what comes to
[inaudible],
what's the effect on my mind of looking
at my twitter at mentioned?
So I wondered that when you were asking
people what kind of questions they said,
yeah,
we should ask what some of this podcast.
Sometimes it's incredibly useful.
I was thinking of what you're doing.
You're opening yourself up to the green
frog,
but I've had both kinds of experience.
I've had people send me articles that I
would have never found otherwise and
fascinating,
super useful and it's just,
it's like this is the perfect use of
this technology and then again,
then I,
then I get this river of green frogs and
weirdness,
but the.
But the to the previous point,
I pay attention to something for long
stretches of time rather than do in
something I know is good for me with my
attention.
I kind of spin the roulette wheel with,
with twitter and rather often there's
just this kind of toxic undercurrent of,
of mental activity that it produces in
me that I'm mean.
It doesn't make me feel.
I mean,
it doesn't equip me to do anything
better in life.
It doesn't make me feel any better about
myself or other people.
I mean,
if,
if it has any net effect,
it's.
It basically grabbed a dozen dials that
I can just sort of dimly conceive of in
my mind and turn them all a little bit
toward the negative.
You know,
I feel a little bit worse about myself,
a little bit worse about my career,
a little bit worse about people will go
a little bit worse about the future,
a little bit worse about the fact that I
was doing this when I could have been
playing with my kid or or writing or
thinking productive thoughts or
meditating or doing anything that I know
is that you still do this twitter
compulsion,
you argue with people.
I found that fascinating.
You.
I go,
I go for.
I go for weeks without arguments as
well,
but also you argue with people on your
podcast.
Well,
yeah,
but that's,
that's different.
But I mean it.
Just on the podcast you'll also be
talking about people you're arguing with
on twitter or a.
So the arguing is a part of your.
Well,
I get trolled a lot on twitter.
I get trolled.
You have guests,
you have guests who come on your podcast
and savage me on the podcast and then
troll me endlessly on twitter and abby.
Abby Martin.
Well she was.
No,
she doesn't try.
I mean,
she,
she hates me,
but she,
I don't know.
I haven't noticed her at trolling me,
but no,
you got in a room with her.
Everybody would calm down.
She just has.
There's people that have radical
misconceptions of who you are.
You.
Yeah.
I'm sure you heard the josh steps a
patent Oswald thing or Patton Oswalt
don't,
don't listen to it because he went off
the rails pack,
went off the rails,
like Hannibal style.
When are you thinking of Andy Kindler?
Oh yes.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
That's good.
So sorry.
How do I connect patents?
Great.
Good patents.
Very smart and very reasonable as is
andy for the most,
most of the time.
But so,
so the end is kind of discovered this
very late.
I did it.
So I kept seeing this guy.
I didn't know who he was.
I kept seeing him in my twitter feed,
Andy Kindler and they can learn and then
I realized,
wait a minute.
He is actually,
he seems to be mean.
He's an established comic.
He seems to be friends with people who I
really respect who I don't know.
Like,
you know,
like Sarah Silverman,
who I don't know personally,
I mean we've,
we've communicated a little bit on
twitter,
but it's like I,
I,
I'm just nothing but a pure fan of
Sarah,
Jim Gaffigan,
other big comics,
so I totally respect.
I don't know how close he is with these
people,
but he basically,
he has endless energy for vilifying me
as a racist and a bigot.
Right.
I mean he's just,
he's a madman.
And I discovered so I did a search of
his twitter feed and he's got hundreds
and hundreds of tweets where he's,
he's going after me in the most retail
way.
So for instance,
like I,
I,
I tweeted out a can anyone recommend 500
seat halls and all these cities and I
think your friend is Duncan Trussell,
a friend of yours.
Okay.
So Duncan wrote back saying,
Oh yeah,
Dma,
I've got a great place in Boston or
something.
And then Andy kindler jumped into that
thread talking to Duncan saying,
don't help him,
Duncan,
he's a bigot.
Right?
So like he's like,
this is Andy kindler just got endless
energy for this.
And then I,
then I looked at what he was doing and
he had been doing it for years and I
wasn't aware of it just to you just to
me and Bill Maher,
he hates Bill Maher,
but then you've got another guy on this
podcast.
I'm hunter mats once.
Okay.
So he was on here and I actually had to
go back and watch what he said here
because I had been getting so much of
this on twitter and I mean it's
incredibly common.
People are tweeting at me saying,
why won't you debate hunter is,
is Matt?
Okay,
why won't you debate hunter mass?
I went back and looked at what he said
here,
you know,
half of it frankly didn't make any
sense.
Um,
but his attacks on me on twitter are the
most juvenile.
It's like the idea that he thinks this
is a way he's going to establish a
conversation with me by sending me to
tweets and then sending me 400,
which say you're scared to debate me.
Right?
Um,
it's,
I mean,
I don't know,
maybe it's very,
very,
very smart guy,
but taking a terrible socially retarded
approach to establishing a debate.
And I've contacted Brian Cowen about
this and Brian Cowen contacted hunter
about this.
It's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And he continues to do crazy behavior.
He said he wouldn't do it anymore and
then he gives more.
I mean,
every time I look,
I,
I see him somewhere in there,
but then there's this guy,
Mike Cernovich,
who,
who's actually has effects on the real
world.
I mean,
Mike Cernovich is again,
he's a twitter troll.
Um,
again,
one of these other guys who's challenged
me to debate him and uh,
you know,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's no,
there's absolutely no possibility to
suitable dialogue,
spend less time on twitter,
but Cernovich's was just on 60 minutes.
I mean,
he's like,
he's in the world and he's affecting
people's psyche.
Oh yeah.
Well,
for sure.
Right.
Yeah.
So they can come back.
It's,
it's not,
it's not the nine times out of 10
looking just makes me think,
um,
I mean it's an illusion because if you
met most of these people with you,
if they came up to you at a conference
or at a book signing or so,
you know,
after a Gig of yours and you thought you
had more information about them,
you saw all of the,
you know,
all of the crazy coming out,
um,
you would say,
I don't have to pay any time.
There's no reason to pay attention to
what this guy is saying.
Whereas on twitter,
everything is,
has the same stature.
So whether it's a Washington Post
columnist who's tweeting at me or some,
some guy like hunter who I had no idea
who he is,
but he's telling me I've got something
wrong.
Um,
everything has the same stature and you
just,
there's no signal to noise sense of what
you know.
Well,
first of all,
you fucked up because you talked about
them,
both of them.
You said candy man five times and now
you've got a problem.
You talked about him right now on this
project,
and this is the first time I've ever
mentioned the gun out,
but I'll go in and talk to you before
this.
I'm bringing it to you because you you,
but you created it.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was his.
It was his podcast with you.
They kicked this whole thing on.
100 was going to do that and I know for
a fact that hunter is actually a fan of
yours.
I think when hunter is trying got a
strange way of showing it.
I don't think it's a smart way.
I think what he's trying to do and he,
he,
when I was trying to hold his feet to
the fire and get some sort of a logical
definition of what you do wrong,
he really didn't have anything we'll hit
but he thinks he does and he.
But did he,
when I talked to them about it and send
half of what he said about Dawkins and
me,
it was totally wrong of what he said
about the relevant biology was wrong.
I mean he's just,
he's not.
He doesn't have his shit together,
but he thinks he does and there's this,
there's a,
there's a level of arrogance and,
and in civility and just kind of a lack
of charity in,
in interacting with other people's
views,
which is now kind of getting rebranded
on the Internet as just just American
can do Chutzpah.
Right?
And it's like,
it's,
it's given us trump,
right?
It's like you've got a trump as the
ultimate example.
He's like the cartoon version of,
you know,
a person who doesn't know anything
relevant to the enterprise,
who doesn't show any aptitude for
civilly engaging with differences of
opinion.
And this thing gets amplified to the,
to the place of greatest prominence.
Now in human history,
everyone's on social media or many
people on social media are playing the
same game.
And you know,
Ms Dot Cernovich is another,
you know,
just malignant example of this where you
have someone who's got a fairly large
following.
I mean,
it's not as big as yours,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's a very engaged following.
This whole trump phenomenon has,
has,
uh,
shown me that Pete,
that if a small percentage of,
of one's audience can have like 100
times the energy of the rest of your
audience,
like whenever I went against trump on my
podcast or this is still the case,
the level of,
of pain it causes in,
in the sort of feedback space is
completely out of proportion to the
numbers of people who are,
who are on that side of the argument.
And it's so.
It's incredibly energized,
but it's just this weird style of self
promotion where you'd.
All you do is that you brag about
yourself,
you say you're the best,
you're,
you're someone who has absolutely no
basis to back up those claims.
And yet an audience thrills to that
level of arrogance and an empty boast.
It's just bizarre.
But well there's a,
there's a big issue I think online where
people find likeminded people and then
they develop these communities where
they
just support each other and they,
they just have these,
these gigantic groups of people.
I mean,
not even necessarily gigantic,
but groups of people that find any
subject,
like for me,
you know what it is flat earth,
right?
I get trolled by people all day that
claim I'm a sellout because I don't
believe the earth is flat,
Mrs Reel.
But,
but don't think that there's a,
there's a,
I think this phenomenon that you're
describing is both,
um,
has really serious negative
consequences.
But it also has some beauty on the same.
By the same token,
you've got parents,
uh,
all over the world who've got children
with a rare disease,
but they can connect on the internet and
bond over that and share tips and Dr.
sure.
So it is,
it's actually,
they're both outgrowths of the same kind
of phenomenon,
but he can be a,
we see the,
the really difficult,
uh,
consequences of this in our politics
right now,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I think we're talking about two
different things.
You think.
So I'm talking about confirmation bias.
I'm talking about a bunch of people that
get together and say,
yeah,
obviously I'm woke in the earth is flat
and pay attention.
There's an analogy allows ball,
yes it,
but there are different things.
The groups of people that will find
communities where maybe your child has
autism and there's some sort of an issue
that can be mitigated with diet and
parents have had some success with that
and they could give you some
enlightening information and you can
communicate with each other and that's
nice.
It's beautiful and I'm some of the
hashtags that people use that they find
search through.
It's great,
but you know that these little
communities that you bond,
that they're not those those ideas.
There's no confirmation bias in those
ideas,
but there's confirmation bias and the
idea that trump is the man is
confirmation bias and the idea that the
earth is flat.
You know,
and if you just huddle in those little
communities and just bark the same
noises that everybody else barks,
there's some sort of sense of community
in that too.
And people love that.
They love being a part of a fucking
team.
Even if it's a stupid team of green frog
and you don't have it.
You don't have to listen to other
people's views and you get deeply,
deeply entrenched.
I think we're seeing.
We're seeing this all through our
politics and media right now.
Well,
you also see when you go to those
people's pages,
which I do often,
I don't engage with people in a negative
way online very often.
Very,
very rarely.
Do you not look at your ad mentions,
are you?
A little bit.
But you know what,
man,
I just like to just go on about my day.
I've found that the negative
consequences that you're discussing,
I rare.
It's rare that I go down the rabbit hole
and I go for days without looking at at
mentioned.
I mean it's more that if I publish
something,
if I asked for feedback,
I want to see the feedback.
Silly.
Did anything wrong?
I mean,
just as your friend.
I mean I feel like there's nothing wrong
with.
I look at my app mentions,
but um,
but you can function in a very different
space.
I mean,
you're not pushing controversial stuff.
Definitely not.
So I'm,
I agree.
I'm just fine.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
No,
I was just more worried about,
again,
back to your psyche like it feels like
you need a a little bit of a middle
ground.
I stay offline after UFC is for the most
part.
That's when I get the most crazy.
People said if there's any sort of a
controversial decision,
but are they criticizing you for
something you said or they get fucking
mad at my commentary.
They'll just disagree with who I thought
water and when they're so fucking
vicious about it.
I'm just like,
just yell.
Just yell on your own.
You don't want to see any of that.
There's too many people.
You're dealing with millions and
millions of people and who knows how
many of them are rational when you're
dealing with.
You know,
there's a bit that I had one of my
specials where I was talking about the
number of people that are stupid in the
world.
Like if you get a room full of 100
people,
the idea that one person isn't a
complete fucking idiot.
Of course you're being very charitable
being shared in one,
but if you do that,
we're talking about 300 million people
in the United States.
Plus that's 3 million fucking idiots.
Yeah,
so if you have 3 million fucking idiots
and all your ad mentions,
if you look at your ad mentions and $3
million comments are saying you're a
fucking moron and there's just too many
people.
The numbers are,
they're not manageable.
The numbers of human beings you interact
with online are not manageable.
So anytime anything gets negative or
insulting,
and I just check out.
I just next,
next,
next.
I don't pay attention because you can't.
But if I fucked up and I know I fucked
up,
I think one of the most important things
that I do is I admit that I fuck you and
I talk about it and I apologize and I
say,
look,
I'm flawed.
I'm human.
I made a mistake.
Sorry,
and then just step away.
Let the fucking chaos ensue and the
comments,
but all the people call you a shill and
a whatever.
Let all that happen,
but don't let it in like you're letting
it in and then you stew on it and you
have to bring up,
you know,
a hunter and all these other people and
you're letting them way too.
No,
no,
no.
I perhaps I gave a false impression of,
of how under my skin this has gotten.
Just the fact that you talked about it
at all,
those too much.
Well,
no,
but I think it's a huge consequence and
I think it's given us trump this way,
this way.
The fact that this style of
communication is attractive to so many
people.
The fact that you can bluff and bluster
and empty boast and lives with it being
caught in lies without consequence.
Um,
the fact that the people never admit
mistakes.
I mean the,
the,
what you just described to you,
you do.
And which I do,
you know,
you make a mistake.
You want to hear about it.
You want to correct it as quickly as
possible,
right?
That is the antithesis of what we're
seeing now in this space.
I mean,
it made when has trump admitted a
mistake,
but isn't the difference being that
neither you nor I have any desire to
control anything like I don't.
I don't want to be the leader of
anything.
Well,
no,
but you want effective.
Can we?
You want good ideas too?
I am sure and you want the truth to win.
You want the truth to propagate.
We want facts to
propagate.
You want to be able to correct errors,
whether they're your own or others,
especially when they're consequential.
And I think that we need a.
We need a common ethic where align has
real consequences.
I mean,
so many people are trying to figure out
what's the antidote to fake news?
Well,
one antidote is to be caught.
Line has to be devastating for your
career,
right?
Like it hit politically,
journalistically,
academically as a,
as a public intellectual.
I mean to be caught in a whopping lie
without a will require at minimum some
serious atonement.
And historically it has been absolutely
and it in many spheres
we have slipped those rails just to,
to a degree that I've never thought
possible.
We're going lightspeed right into the
woods.
Yeah,
I mean,
we're talking about people have figured
out how to,
just to use dishonesty as extra fuel.
I mean,
it's like,
it's,
you know,
the whatever the,
the nitrous oxide boost in those hacky
cars,
right?
It's like we can use this stuff,
right.
And the getting the way you behave when
you get caught just,
which is to say,
just go fuck yourself.
Just redounds to your credibility in
your,
among your tribe.
Right.
It's like this guy is so powerful.
He,
he,
he so fully doesn't give a shit what
people think that he can catch him in a
lie and just watch how he,
he gets out of it.
Um,
and,
but that's,
that's what,
what,
what I'm,
when I was bringing up these guys,
Mike Cernovich,
I mean this,
this is,
um,
I actually,
I mean,
I,
I trolled Crna,
I decided to troll Cernovich one day and
I,
I thought it was hilarious and I,
it was just nothing but fun.
So there was only topic about that.
But,
but the thing that bothers me is that
this has real political consequences.
And I think that this is a,
this is a time period where we're in the
sort of adolescent stage of
communication online where you can get
away
saying things that are dishonest and
that there might be some sort of a way
to mitigate that in the future.
There might be some.
I don't think we should act like
dishonesty and bluff and bluster to use
a phrase you used before is started
somehow knew to the human repertoire.
I get that.
The acceptance of it seems to be though
I think we're in a period where that is
true and I think it is aided and abetted
by technology and social networks.
I agree with your diagnosis on many
levels.
But I,
you know,
I was having an interesting conversation
with a guy that you introduced me to
Joseph Goldstein,
who was a,
uh,
eminent meditation teacher,
become my meditation teacher,
old friend of Sam's.
And he was saying,
we were talking about the current
political situation.
He used a phrase that I like when I was
asking him what he thought about it,
he said,
I'm kind of slotting into geological
time.
And I think that actually makes some
sense not to say that.
What does that mean?
Meaning that I'm just viewing it from a
far.
I'm widening the Lens to look at the
broad scope of human history to see
that,
you know,
over time we've got these ups and downs.
He's getting to the top of the mountain
near Denver with a big bucket of
Margarita.
So that's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
I just lucked out with binoculars,
watch the bombs go off,
learn how to get water out of the
ground,
get a solar powered generator and make
good Margarita.
I mean,
it just doesn't seem to me that this is
sustainable.
It feels like this is just going to be
some spectacular moment in history where
people were Rah Rah Nixon and now they
look back and go,
my God,
Nixon was a fucking liar and a buffoon.
I mean,
take
this.
This is a point I've made before and I
don't think it's original with me.
I think other people have made it,
but my,
my claim is that if trump were one 10th
as bad,
he would appear much worse.
Because like everything he does now is
as appearing against a background of so
many lies and so much craziness that you
can barely even weight its value.
But yeah,
I mean just so I just,
uh,
this is one of the things I find useful
about twitter because I follow some very
interesting people.
And so Anne Applebom,
The Washington Post columnist,
it was just awesome on twitter.
Everyone should follow her.
She just keeps hammering trump with,
with her own points and other stuff that
she finds.
And um,
she just pointed out that.
Did anyone notice that trumped trump
threatened a war with North Korea two
days ago?
It was in the financial times and yet no
one can talk about it because no one
believes him,
right?
Like,
it's like,
it's like we have a president whose
speech has now become so denuded of
truth value,
right?
Perceived truth value that he can say,
you know,
where if China doesn't handle North
Korea,
we're going to.
And no one even feels like they have to
ask a followup question on that topic
because it just,
everyone assumes as an empty bluff.
I mean,
images imagined,
like you've just stepped back into the
previous presidency of Obama had said,
if China doesn't handle North Korea,
we will write.
That would be top of the fold.
This is all we're talking about today,
right?
Like it's just comes out of a blizzard
of,
of inanity and craziness that,
that,
you know,
he's,
he's going after Meryl Streep is,
he's lying about Obama wiretapping him
now his,
he's threatening war with North Korea
and you know,
nobody knows what to talk about.
So it's like the,
the,
the consequence of this is we have a
president who not only can he not be
trusted to tell the truth,
he can be trusted to lie when ever he
thinks that suits his purpose.
And now so,
so,
so the,
the,
the state of mind that everyone's in,
including the press in listening to him
is just his to take potentially the most
serious things in the world.
Not seriously and the least serious
things in the world.
Like,
you know,
Meryl Streep or what he thinks of her
acting,
you know,
that becomes a,
that dominates a whole new cycle.
It's very upside down,
it seems to be to be quite new as
opposed to the or are perennial,
but I feel like we're in a very
different space now with the
consequences of of misinformation and we
certainly are.
Do you think that they're connected to
what we're talking about before we said
that people would rather be electrocuted
than to be alone with their thoughts
that we have gotten to this weird place
with our society,
with our civilization where we've made
things so easy and made people so soft,
so dependent upon technology.
We've slotted out these paths,
these predetermined patterns of behavior
to people for people to follow where
they can just sort of plug into a
philosophy,
whether it's a right wing or left wing,
one with very little room for personal
thought at all.
Very little room for objective
reasoning.
We've sort of made it easy.
We baby.
I do think that it's imperative if you
want to be a good citizen to have a
varied media diet,
you're not going to have a clear view of
the world.
If all you're reading it well for the
New York Times,
you know,
I think you have nothing against the New
York Times or bright part,
but I think you need to read many things
and follow up many different sorts of
people on twitter,
not just because you want to troll them,
but because you actually want to listen
to what they have to say and take it
serious.
Well,
the New York Times really fucked up
where they're really fucked up is well,
they said that they're going to
the election.
They're going to rededicate themselves
to reporting the truth and read like,
what?
Why'd she say that?
Like,
I wish I was there.
I wish I was in the office.
Why?
That just sends the wrong message.
We weren't into the truth that says they
are biased.
They fucked up.
I mean,
as they were by saying,
you're right,
the enemy is,
is was so grotesque in this case that it
was impossible to not have been biased.
Seemed an abdication of responsibility
and I feel it myself like people.
Everything I say against trump from a
trump person sounds like mirror partisan
bias.
There's zero connection to the
Democratic Party or two.
I mean it's like,
uh,
there's,
there's no partisan bias and that every
100 percent of what I want to say about
trump does not apply to some other
Republican who,
who,
uh,
is just a stands for things that I don't
know,
policies I might not like.
It's completely,
completely unique circumstance and um,
yeah,
so I mean it's true that you went to
read the New York Times for the longest
time it was,
it was reading like just the thing had
become
the opinion page on the Huffington post
or something.
Yeah.
I just feel like at this stage of our,
our society,
there's real consequences to the infant
tylenol if that's actually a word of,
of human beings in our culture.
We've made it very easy to just go to
work and just get home and watch
television and just not pay attention to
anything and not read anything and not
really think and,
and then be manipulated.
I mean,
I think it's incredibly easy to
manipulate people,
especially people that are aware that
they don't have a varied media diet.
People that are aware that they don't
have a real sense of the word and there
seems daunting to try to take into
consideration like what is,
what is involved in foreign policy,
what is involved in dealing with Russia,
what is involved?
How do you negotiate with North Korea?
Fuck,
it's too much.
Put it in the hands of the strong man.
This is true on both sides of the
spectrum though because I think we've
got folks um,
who,
who slot into just a,
a,
a media diet where they're just hearing
things on the left and they're not,
they're not curious about or uh,
um,
I guess just just not curious enough to
hear things from a different perspective
unless it's just some right wing
political who comes on and they beat
them up.
Um,
so I,
I,
I really do think and I think it put
places,
and this is going to be a self serving
argument,
but I do think it places increasing
important sun media outlets like the one
for which I work to be really vigilant
about being seen as fair arbiters or
fax.
Yeah.
I think the consequences have never been
greater for that.
Absolutely.
The reason that so many people on the
right,
somebody trump's support supporters
fear,
feel like they're right is because it
has been proven that the media was
biased and that they did get it all
wrong and they were absolutely wrong
when it came to who was going win.
The huffington post has some ridiculous
thing where it was the night of the
election and they said that Hillary had
like a 98 percent chance of winning or
something crazy like that.
Well,
I think there were some polls that were
bad,
but the pole like the,
because I remember this because I sent
out a tweet which said like by,
by Donald or something like that,
the day of.
But when I did that,
I mean that wasn't a prediction and the,
the,
the polls that I was going by that most
people were going by that point,
it was like 80 slash 20,
you know,
or at best 75 slash 25 that she was
going to win.
Now that's not.
I mean,
you roll dice for a few minutes,
you realize 20 percent chance comes up a
lot,
so I guess that's infinite test.
Melodic plus Florida.
Yeah,
but,
so,
but.
Well,
you should,
you should tell the story about what it
was like to anchor.
Yeah,
well I guess.
Yeah.
So I was anchoring the ABC News digital
coverage that night.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
they,
they give you the exit polling,
well you're not supposed to report it
publicly,
but the exit polling that we were seeing
before we went on the air late in the
day really made it seem like it's going
to be a Clinton landslide.
And now you have all these folks who
say,
look at the crest fallen faces of the
journalists because they're so upset
that trump won.
Certainly that was not the case for the
folks on my set was that it was,
that we didn't see it coming.
We weren't prepared for it.
Everything that we're seeing in terms of
the math made it look like this was a
Clinton victory.
A shoe in.
It was just about just tying a ribbon
around it.
So when the night became long,
there was just confusion about what was
going on,
how do they get it so wrong.
You know,
I think it actually goes back to what
Sam was saying before that people think
when you see numbers like 70 percent is
that Clinton's going to win 80 percent
odds that Clinton's going to win that,
that she's definitely going to win.
But there's room there for trump to a
lot of room there for whatever
present comes up all the time.
It's Russian roulette bills or bad.
If it's Russian roulette,
those are bad odds.
Right?
You're not going to take that one single
bullet,
right?
Yeah.
No,
you're a hunter.
Yeah.
That's really good.
Awesome.
I don't think so.
It's so much about blaming the polls as
it was blaming the overall tenor of the
coverage,
which made it seem like Clinton was
inevitable.
Yeah.
It just,
it was.
It was so shocking.
That's a hit.
I think that we,
we can and should take.
Yeah,
we definitely know.
I think we,
we weren't giving the 20 or 30 percent
chance a serious enough look.
What is your thought as being someone
who covers these things?
What is your thought about the electoral
college?
Do you think that that's an antiquated
idea and then,
I mean,
it was kind of established back when you
really needed a representative because
otherwise you would have to get on a
fucking horse and ride into Washington
and it would take six months.
I can see the,
you can make very powerful arguments
that it's deeply problematic
institution.
I can see the,
I can see the power of those arguments
for sure.
Um,
there are people who argue make similar
arguments about the United States
Senate.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
there was,
there was a piece that ran in the New
York Times,
uh,
in their Sunday we can review not long
after the election making the case that
the angriest people in America actually
should be those live on the coast
because it's taxation without
representation that we,
that the people who live on the coast
are paying more in taxes,
but they have less representation
actually in Washington.
Um,
again,
this,
I,
that's not research that I've done,
but it's an interesting idea.
Have you ever seen anybody present any
sort of a logical argument that there
really shouldn't be a president anymore,
that the idea of having one alpha champ
run this whole thing seems pretty
outdated and just not sure that he runs
the whole thing,
but he's got a lot of info.
It's an enormous amount of influence,
but,
but we're seeing Donald Trump is seeing
right now the limits of presidential
power.
He couldn't get his,
uh,
the healthcare bill that they,
that didn't even make it wasn't even
close to what he promised on the,
or in some ways wasn't even close to
what he promised in the campaign trail.
In other words,
he couldn't get the bill that he wanted
and then he couldn't get that passed.
And now he's looking at having to watch
his party employed the nuclear option in
order to get a,
his supreme court nominee a seated.
So I,
I don't know.
I think that the founders designed in
many ways a really ingenious system and
we put a lot of attention on the
president because it's one person who
get who's in our on our TV screens or
our phones all the time,
but I'm not sure how much power is
vested in that person.
Now when it comes to foreign policy,
it's a different kettle of fish.
Well,
it's enough that the EPA has been sort
of hobbled.
I mean what they've done with the
environmental protection agency
standards,
especially when it regards to emissions.
He's rolled back emission standards.
I mean there's anything that we should
be concerned about.
It's the air that we breathe and we are
moving in a direction we.
We're clearly moving in a direction to
get away from things like coal and he's
going the opposite way.
Not only that,
but what I've heard is that that's not
even going to be effective because most
places have moved away from coal to the
point where restarting coal production
is not even gonna recharge the economy
in the way that would make it a viable
option in the first place.
The issue of climate change is just,
um,
I'll say as a member of the media and
area where I feel,
I'm just speaking for myself,
I'm really one of our biggest failures,
um,
and I don't think history is going to go
just kindly and I get off,
I'll put the blame on myself.
It's become,
it's a hard story to get people just
interested in,
um,
and especially for television because
it's a lot of sort of graphs and
science.
Um,
and you,
there's only so many pictures of polar
bears you can show.
Um,
and so I've,
I anguish about that because I do think
it's,
uh,
there isn't a debate.
Climate change is real,
almost certainly caused by humans.
I don't think we.
And for too long we fell for that in the
media where we presented it as a debate
when it wasn't a.
Now I think we're past that,
but I still don't think we're covering
it enough and as robustly as we should.
Climate change I think is very sort of
almost abstract to people.
It's very difficult for them to wrap
their head around,
especially when they look at the ice
core samples and there's plenty of stuff
online where you could sort of convince
yourself that there's always been this
rise and fall of the temperature on the
earth.
In many ways that is true,
but pollution is another thing.
I think.
I think actually I just walked in so I
might have missed what you said there,
but I think that's a crucial shift of
emphasis.
There is no
argument about air pollution runs
consequences.
It's undesirability.
I mean like you don't want particulates
in your lungs that you don't need to
have there.
And the idea that we could see,
you could completely justify a green
economy on that basis alone.
Maybe it just imagine if we had no
pollution coming from the exhaust of all
the cars out there and there was no coal
fired power plants.
We just had solar and wind and and you
know,
safe nuclear technology powering the
grid.
It will be fantastic from just a pure.
I mean forget about the health.
It just taught me the,
obviously cancers is,
is a lung cancer and,
and cardiovascular diseases is a huge
issue there.
But just aesthetically it's,
it's so desirable.
I mean,
there's no argument against it and
that's,
I feel like people don't make that
connection
because climate change is slow moving,
you know,
and it could be way out in the future
before pollution isn't.
I know,
you know,
but it pollution is a much less
controversial than climate change.
Well,
that's why this coal thing,
so disturbing.
Reigniting this production of coal.
Yeah,
it's unbelievable.
It's ridiculous.
I mean,
I guess I have questions about whether
it's even going to happen.
In other words,
you can roll it back.
But the coal industry,
there are many,
many,
uh,
they,
they are many factors to their decision
making about,
for example,
will,
if they go and do the mining is,
is what they,
uh,
a mine going to actually even be
consumed.
So I uh,
you know,
and I,
I think that even though they're doing
some pretty radical,
making some pretty radical noises at the
EPA,
I'm not sure how far pruitt can,
can take some of this stuff given the
existing body of law case law that has
formed around a Obama's decisions.
So I think it gets,
it gets pretty more complicated the
closer you look at it,
from what I can tell and I won't claim
to have studied it too too closely,
but it seems to get more complicated.
The more you look at it,
the headlines maybe scarier,
I guess is my point.
Well,
what's pretty clear though is emission
standards rolling
back emission standard sends a very
clear message that it's okay to pollute
the air.
I mean it's,
we were moving in a direction of going
towards electric cars,
going towards cars that pollute the
environment less.
I mean even cars that use gas,
you know,
for a Porsche,
porsche has a nine slash 11 turbo and
the standards of emissions are so
strong.
What they've developed as a car that you
drive it through La,
the exhaust that comes out is cleaner
than the air.
It sucks in.
Hmm.
Imagine that you're driving through.
It's an air filter.
Yeah.
It really is bad air filter.
It can be done very expensive hair
filming.
It can be done.
I mean that's.
I mean,
and we can move further and further
away.
I mean obviously the problem with that
is it's taking in polluted air.
That's the issue in the first place.
I mean it's not clean.
You don't want to breathe the exhaust of
a Porsche,
but what they've done is managed to make
something so efficient that it actually
does emit clean air coming out of it or
cleaner than the polluted air that it's
sucking in.
Now,
if these environmental protection agency
standards keep getting rolled back,
I mean we're going to go back to.
I mean I don't know how far the rolling
it back,
but what you said is so clear.
There's nothing good about polluting the
air.
I mean it's what we need to breathe and
there's options.
The idea that business should take
precedent over the actual environment
that we need to sustain ourselves.
So let's not forget there are a real
human beings in coal country who have
generations of,
I've done,
have spent generations working in the
industry,
take great pride in it,
and we've got to think about what we do.
It's only the numbers here as uprising
and also little reported.
It's only 75,000
coal jobs we're talking about in the
country and there's something like
500,000
clean tech jobs just in California
alone.
I mean,
the numbers are completely out of it.
No,
I think.
I think the cleantech to,
um,
uh,
industry offers an enormous amount of
promise,
but 75,000
families is not nothing.
And when we're talking about and give
them money,
they don't want to end up going to work.
This goes to the question of meaning and
you know,
like what are we going to do?
Because we're on the precipice.
We're getting to is everyone.
Virtually everyone is going to be in the
position of these coal miners.
When,
when you were talking about and that
that's a good thing.
That's the thing,
I mean,
that's,
that's why can't they figure out that
they just want to learn new languages
and spend more time with their kids and
play Frisbee and,
and uh,
have fun.
We need a new ethic that and politics
that decouples a person's claim on
existence from doing profitable work
that someone will pay you for.
It says a lot of that work is going on.
We could,
I mean,
we could view it as an opportunity and
it is actually something that it does
dovetail with this hobby horse that you
and I have been on for awhile about,
about,
um,
kind of about the power of meditation
and what it can do to a human mind and
the way you view the world and your role
in it.
For sure.
What are you thoughts on universal basic
income?
Because bring,
bring it back to that with this rise of
the machines.
If we do have things automated,
I mean some ridiculous number of people
make their living driving cars and
driving trucks now when that,
when those jobs are gone,
I think it's millions of people.
It's,
I think it is in the states,
it's the most common job for white men.
I think something like 9 million white
men are driving trucks and cars,
and the problem with that is most people
like fuck white men,
white men,
patriarchy.
This is trump's.
Yeah,
no,
it's these,
um,
I think universal basic income.
There,
there reasons to worry that it's not a
perfect solution because you do want,
you want to incentivize the things you
want to incentivize you to.
You need to just understand the
consequences of,
of any system you would put in place,
but there's just no question that in the
viewed as an opportunity,
this is,
this is the greatest opportunity in
human history.
We're talking about canceling the need
for dangerous,
boring,
repetitive work and freeing up humanity
to do interesting,
creative,
fun things.
Now,
how could that be bad?
Well,
give us a little time and we'll show you
how we can make it bad,
but it'll,
it'll be bad if it leads to just
extraordinary wealth inequality that we
have.
We don't have the political or ethical
will to,
to fix.
And because if we have a culture of
people who think I don't want any
handouts and I certainly don't want my
neighbor to get any handouts and I don't
want to pay any taxes so that he gets,
he can be a lazy bum if that's the,
if we have this,
you know,
hangover from,
from,
uh,
calvinism,
you know,
that makes it impossible to talk
creatively and reasonably about what has
changed.
Yeah.
That it could be a very painful
bottleneck we have to pass through until
we get to something that is,
that is,
um,
much better or a hell of a lot worse
depending on,
on where the technology goes.
And I think at a certain point the,
the wealth inequality will be obviously
unsustainable.
I mean,
you can't have multiple trillionaires
walking around living in compounds with
razor wire and just moving everywhere by
private jet.
Um,
and then,
you know,
massive levels of unemployment in a
society like ours.
I mean,
at a certain point where the richest
people will realize that enough is
enough.
We have to spread this wealth because
otherwise people are just going to show
up at our compounds with,
with their ar fifteens or their
pitchforks and you know,
that the society will not sustain it,
mean you can't use the,
there has to be some level of wealth
inequality that is unsustainable that
people,
people will not tolerate.
Um,
and you begin to look more and more like
a banana republic until you become a
banana republic.
But now we were talking about,
you know,
the US or,
or the developed world where all the
wealth is a.
So redistribution is the end game.
We and that's that.
But that's a toxic concept for half of
the country right now where the idea of
the welfare state in perpetuating that
and spreading it across the board.
Yeah.
But these are so,
yeah,
I mean,
whatever the solution is for coal
mining,
we should not be hostage for the coal
miners.
We should not be hostage to the idea
that they need jobs so that whatever job
they were doing and are still qualified
to do that job has to continue to exist
no matter what.
No matter what the environmental
consequences,
no matter what the health consequences,
no matter well how it closes the door to
good things that we,
we want,
we don't do that with any that we didn't
do that with the people who are making
buggy whips or,
or anything.
Slavery.
Yeah.
Or Yeah.
I mean that's just,
there's no,
I'm at a certain point we move on and we
make progress and we don't let that
progress get rolled back.
And when you're talking about a
developing technology that produces
energy that doesn't have any of these
negative effects,
um,
you know,
whether it's global climate change or
just pollution,
of course we have to move in that
direction.
And the other thing that's crazy is that
we're not talking honestly about how the
dirty tech is subsidized.
I mean,
you have the oil.
People say,
well,
solar is all subsidized,
right?
This is,
is this a government handout that's
given us the solar industry?
Well,
one,
that's not even that you have to produce
an argument as to why that's a bad
thing.
We,
this is something we should want the
government to do.
The government needs to incentivize new
industries that the market can't
incentivize.
Now,
if there are industries that are just
intrinsically good and are going to lead
to the betterment of humanity,
but carbon is massively subsidized.
We Ha,
we don't have,
I mean if we actually had the,
the,
the coal producers,
um,
and the,
and the petroleum producers pay for the
consequences of,
of carbon and pollution.
It would be,
it would be much more expensive than it
is,
right?
So it's already subsidized,
you know,
we do it.
So we should,
I mean,
we,
we need a carbon tax.
Clearly we need to the tax code to
incentivize what we want to incentivize.
Well,
there's a ton of industries in this
country that you could make that
argument for.
The corn industry is one subsidizing the
corn industry and when you find out the
corn and corn syrup is responsible for.
I'm just a huge epidemic of obesity in
this country.
And the amount of corn syrup that's in
foods.
If you have USA,
USA polluter had to pay the,
the consequences of your pollution all
the way down the line,
right?
Um,
you had to compensate everyone who got
emphysema or lung cancer because of what
you were putting into the air,
your industry,
it would be less profitable,
right.
And it might not be profitable at all
and that's,
and we don't have,
we haven't priced all of that in to any
of things,
whether you're talking about,
you know,
the,
the chemical industry or,
or,
or the industry.
I mean,
we're,
we're addicted to the use of these
fossil fuels the same way we're addicted
to some people are addicted to the use
of cigarettes when the health
consequences of those things are there,
they're almost parallel and a lot of
ways.
Yeah.
Well and amazingly,
as you have the same,
I mean,
I think you turned me onto this
documentary.
What was it,
merchants of doubt that the same phds
you got like 10 guys who moved from
India,
you know,
just toxic industry to toxic industry
defending whether it's big tobacco or
the.
I'm in the document a,
I interviewed a guy named Fred Singer
who was one of these people.
Uh,
and uh,
he's a climate change denier and there's
just some,
um,
it's been awhile that it was,
there were some key moments where I was
like listening,
listening for him,
all the major scientific organizations
that say that climate change is real and
that humans are our major contributors
to it and he basically just refused to
accept it.
Those shows where you have the three
heads,
you and then the two experts and they
yell over each other and then we'll,
we'll be right back.
And then you go to commercial fucking
things on solving anything,
those weird moments where people are
yelling at each other and you can't
figure out who's right or who's wrong.
I'm not a big fan of that personally.
And I think that especially it was a
failure to do that with climate change
because it,
it,
it created the doubt,
it created the doubt.
Um,
and I think that was a very successful.
It was a very successful strategy.
But,
but that's intention intention with what
we just said about the New York Times.
Because if you,
if you take a position as a journalist,
if you say,
okay,
actually one side of this conversation
is full of Shit,
then you seem like you're not an
information.
I think it's different to take us a,
a position.
I don't know.
It's not controversial for me to sit
here and say,
if you smoke cigarettes,
uh,
the science strongly suggest you have a
higher odds of lung cancer.
Same thing with climate change,
but it became politicized.
So I don't feel.
I don't,
you'll notice I've stepped out of some
of the discussions that have been taking
place because it's not my role as
journalists to come down on one side or
another.
But with climate change,
I feel absolutely comfortable saying
this.
The,
the,
the vast majority of scientists believe
this is real and a big,
big problem.
So I don't what,
what you're talking about with the New
York Times and I don't really.
I'm not going to step out and take a
view on it,
but what,
what I believe you're saying with the
times is that they were pro Clinton and
anti trump.
That's different from having a position
on climate change.
Well,
it's not.
Well no,
because they have a position on just
just take the Lens as climate change.
You have one candidate who's denying the
reality of climate change.
Where?
Who's,
who's just claiming that the,
the Chinese trump?
Well,
no,
because it was.
Because when trump says climate change
is a Chinese hoax,
you have to call him.
Here we go.
He said it's a Chinese hoax,
so he should go to China and see those
people that are walking around with gas
masks on because they can't breathe in
Beijing.
Okay.
But that's,
I mean,
that's,
that's the pollution argument,
which I think is actually much stronger
because just you can't go to Beijing and
say this is how we want the air to be.
Right?
Uh,
but I think something like 20,
I think something like 25 percent of the
air pollution in California on some days
is coming from China.
Maybe there's some amazing.
I could have that slightly wrong.
Jamie can check that out,
but please do.
There's some,
there's some extraordinary amount of air
air pollution that we get from China.
That's insane.
I did not know that yet.
Just makes its way across the ocean.
There's no wall build that wall.
Um,
but no,
but at a certain point,
I mean there's some,
there's some level of dishonesty and
misinformation that's so egregious that
if you're a journalist,
commit at all committed to being an
unbiased or disinterested broker of
information and a conversation.
If you set up a conversation between,
you know,
the Sean Spicer's of the world or,
or the Kellyanne Conway's who have their
alternative facts and someone who's
honestly talking about whatever it is,
climate change,
um,
it's very,
you know,
you can't split that baby,
but I don't think you have to create
mock unnecessary debates around climate
change.
What I do think is that,
uh,
with the trump administration,
that it is imperative for journal that
journalists a call out,
uh,
when things are said that aren't true,
but that I don't think it's constructive
for mainstream journalistic
organizations to have an openly hostile
anti trump attitude or pro somebody else
attitude because then you lead.
That just leads to further polarization.
But when it's exactly what we don't
need,
but you call him out on all the times
that he said things that were just
absolutely not true.
Absolutely.
It was like you're anti trump.
Yes it can.
There's no question.
And I think that's a issue we're dealing
with and I,
but I think this is a time of real soul
searching in my industry because I,
I firmly believe there is a very
powerful place in a functioning
democracy for a press,
for,
for media that people generally view as
fair.
Well,
it's also really highlights the
responsibility of getting accurate and
unbiased information to people because
there's not a lot of sources of that
left.
Mean when you look at Fox News and
sometimes you look at CNN,
sometimes you look at him and Msnbc and
you're like,
boy,
how much of this is editorialized?
How much of this is opinion?
You know it.
You need unbiased facts and you almost
need it not delivered by people.
You know,
the
problem is when,
when people are delivering the news,
like I,
I,
when you talk to someone,
you know,
they're educated in an ivy league
university and they speak a certain way,
they act a certain way.
You almost kinda assume that these
intellectual people,
these well read people are going to sort
of lean towards one way or another.
I think that there,
there is that issue.
I,
I would argue,
and again I know this is self serving,
but I still believe it,
that the three broadcast networks have
actually fared quite well in what is a
incredibly difficult environment,
right?
So you don't Count Fox as a broadcast
network.
Fox News as a cable network,
but Fox,
uh,
but they don't have.
Fox broadcast does not have a news
division.
ABC,
CBS and NBC do
so just broadcast meaning traditional
old school signaling the air that nobody
uses anymore.
Nobody uses them.
But we will refer to them within the
industry as the three broadcast.
And that bizarre though it is,
it is.
Well,
some people,
you know,
they put up their rabbit ears and get
the signal.
Fuck those cord cutters,
extreme cord cutters.
Jv He got was 20 bucks if I get like 30
channels and it's way better and it
works.
There's no lagging,
there's no buffering.
You do that.
And then you get like Netflix for Hulu
and I have sling.
But when I wanna watch a basketball game
like this,
the Ncaa basketball tournament last
night,
I had to walk through the air at work.
Really good.
Wow.
Interesting.
It's like a collection tool.
What's the,
what's the viewer benefits on a,
um,
an evening news broadcast.
And I was like 5 million now it's around
eight or nine.
Yeah.
So this is a really big number.
I don't know,
I don't follow all of the,
uh,
ticks,
um,
when it comes to the numbers,
so I can't answer that accurately,
but people have been predicting the
demise of network news for decades now.
Every,
you know,
I've been at ABC news for 17 years.
I've been reading obituaries all
throughout that time.
Eight dollars million a night on each of
the networks is still out.
That is a gigantic number,
especially in an age of complete,
you know,
of micro,
uh,
information of niche broadcasting and
the Internet.
It's all that.
Here are the numbers right there,
NBC.
So ABC's in the lead
ABC is the lead in total viewers.
Uh,
so and ABC and NBC and this is just one
week,
March 27th right around eight.
And then CBS is six point five.
So gets a lot of people excuse super old
though because it does because that
demographic,
absolutely as soon as excused.
Very,
very old.
Well,
it's all people.
That's the majority is people over 54 or
under 25,
but I don't think that's the case at 25
to 54.
ABC as one point.
6 million as opposed to a 8 million
total viewers.
NBC,
seven,
eight,
seven point 8 million total viewers.
One point 7 million.
Twenty five to 54.
And then CBS,
six point $4 million total.
One point $3.
Twenty five to 54.
It's funny.
Like after 54.
Fuck you put before 25.
Fuck.
You concentrate on this one.
It is what advertisers want.
It's funny,
the vitality.
Yeah,
it's gonna be the ads,
the ads you run.
It's like,
you know,
that are anti inflammatory in,
on the morning because in the morning
shows where we're also,
it's more,
it's closer to four or $5 million for
ABC and NBC and a little less for CPS.
Uh,
the percentage of that audience that
falls within the demo as we call it,
25 to 54 is higher.
And so the ads are kind of different.
But I guess my point is that you still
have a really significant number of
people if you take the mornings and
evenings on these broadcast networks
that are getting their news from these
places,
which just gets back to the
polarization,
the polarized media atmosphere you were
talking about before.
I think in this atmosphere that the,
that having the networks be seen to a
certain extent.
To the extent possible as above.
The fright actually is important for
democracy is Alex Jones get was I think
40 million a week,
but they include like a website hits and
they're big number.
So it's a skewed number.
I've spent some time with him to have
you know him very well.
I went down to Boston and I went down to
Austin and sent.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How long a basically spent a day at
hanging around his operation.
This was,
and I would say 2009.
It was a while ago before the
monolithic.
Pretty big back then,
but not what it is now
in 1999.
Alex Jones and I put on George Bush,
senior and junior masks and we smoked
pot out of a bong and then danced around
the white,
not the White House,
the capital building in in Texas for a
standup video that I did.
Yeah.
I've been friends with that guy since
99.
I listened.
I listened to your recent podcast with,
which was just it'll dimensional child
molesters that are infiltrating our
airwaves.
Yeah,
he,
he went deep.
We got them high and drunk and he went.
It's amazing.
He went as deep as he's ever gotten
before.
Do you find that he is different when
he's not being recorded?
Uh,
yeah.
Are there,
is there,
is screaming and yelling.
That's him singing,
by the way.
No,
it's the.
He made up these lyrics.
This song is all him.
I believe he might've ad libbed it to
give us.
Give me some volume on this.
Oh,
that was the name of my dvds,
belly of the beast from Austin,
Texas.
Strap yourselves.
That's Alex.
he's so crazy.
I mean,
he's definitely different when he's not
being recorded,
but he is that guy,
you know,
he believes it's sincere.
People leaves all this stuff.
He believes a lot of it.
I mean,
whether it's correct or not,
that's a different argument whether or
not he believes it.
I was struck and we had,
I spent a full day with them and then we
had dinner with him afterwards who were
not recorded.
And uh,
I was struck by the difference in
demeanor,
uh,
off camera and not being rent.
Yeah,
there's definitely that.
I mean,
not saying that,
leave it.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna.
I can't,
I'm not sure.
He's a showman for sure.
What's really disturbing is when he gets
stuff right.
You know,
like the World Trade Organization is a
perfect example.
He was one of the ones that highlighted
the use of a agent provocateurs now what
agency,
who hires these people,
but what they do is they take something
like the WTO,
which was a big embarrassment that
people were protesting the WTO and they
hire people to turn this peaceful
protest into a violent protest,
so these people come in,
they were ski masks,
they break windows and they light things
on fire or do whatever they do that
makes it violent and then they have the
cops come in and break it up because now
it's no longer a peaceful protest and so
it got to the point where people were
trying to show up for work.
They had WTO Pinzon that aligned through
it well.
They had created a no protest zone and
they were taking his on footage on the
news.
They were telling people,
you have to take the pin off.
You can't go through this area where you
work with a WTO pin on your backpack or
on your jacket.
I mean,
that's crazy,
and he highlighted that and made a in
that use of agent provocateurs has been
documented.
This is a real thing and it's a real
tactic that again,
what agency,
what,
what faction of the military would
fashion the government hires these
people to do that I don't know,
but it is a real thing and I did not
know about that until Alex highlighted
it on one of his V,
one in one of his videos.
It's been proven.
It's been proven that it's real and so
that alone is disturbing when you stop
and think about all the different things
that he's informed.
People of that turned out were real like
operation northwoods when the freedom of
Information Act came out with the
operation northwoods document where the
Joint Chiefs of staff at sign this and
this was something that they were really
trying to implement.
They were going to arm Cuban friendlies
and have them attack,
wanted them obey.
They were going to blow up a drone
jetliner.
They're going to blame it on the Cubans
and they were trying to use this as
impetus to get us to go to war with
Cuba.
You have,
but how do you feel about the things
that he's talking about that are well,
okay,
but let's talk about that first.
I mean,
there are things that are true.
That's what gets really squirrely.
What gets really squirrel.
He's like when when you find out that
there have been things like the Gulf of
Tonkin incident,
like there's many things that have
happened where there have been false
where the government
has conspired to lie to the American
people and people have died because of
it I think will.
I don't know a lot about Gulf of Tonkin,
but although I know more about it than
than those other examples.
I mean there are definitely cases where
it's an additional interpretation to say
that the government lied to take even
something that's closer to hand.
Like we have weapons of mass destruction
as a pretext to go into Iraq right now.
It's one thing to say that people
knowingly lied about that Bush and
Cheney knowingly lied to the American
people about that or they were misled by
people who are knowingly lying or just
everyone got it wrong.
Yeah.
Like it was just.
It was.
It was totally plausible to everyone who
was informed that he had a WMD program
and they misinterpreted whatever
evidence they thought they had and they
were just wrong.
Now.
So that's a spectrum.
I'm not claiming to know which one of
those is true.
I think it's probably probably the last
is much closer to the truth and that
explains many of these instances.
But the,
the,
I mean that was so corrosive about pure
examples of line,
um,
is that,
uh,
and we may have one case now this just
emerging in the news.
I don't know if the,
maybe the,
the,
the story has been clarified while we've
been talking,
but this is now seems that Susan Rice
came out at one point,
she said she knew nothing about the
unmasking of,
of trump associates in this recent
surveillance case.
And now it seems that she is claiming
that she actually asked to have certain
names,
unmasked and stuff like this.
This is being seized upon again,
just in the last few hours as an
example,
an example of a lie.
Right?
Which seems very sinister.
I'm at,
but as though it equalizes the two sides
here,
right?
Let's low.
So let's say worst case scenario,
Susan Rice lied about having some
knowledge of this investigation.
Um,
that doesn't.
It says something bad about Susan Rice.
It says something.
I mean,
she has to deal with the consequences of
that lie,
but it doesn't exonerate all of the line
that trump has done about everything
under the sun.
Right?
So w what so destabilizing here is at
the moment,
the moment ms dot even true of honest
errors,
the moment that a news organization like
yours or the New York Times commits an
honest error that it gets pointed to
from those who want to treat the
mainstream news media as fake news as
see everything's the same.
Like,
like,
like you're no better than than somebody
who's just manufacturing fake news on a
laptop in his basement.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
and,
and the flip side of that is when Alex
Jones get something right,
it seems to,
it seems to make him look like a,
a dignified journalistic enterprise
analogous to the New York Times or to
ABC News.
And neither of those things are true.
I mean,
there are small lies and then they're a
huge lives.
There are honest mistakes,
but be committed by totally reputable
organizations that are really trying to
get their facts straight.
And then there are malicious that's just
militia malicious propaganda outlets
that are not at all trying to get their
facts straight and trying to engineer
everyone's credulity and ignorance into
something that is just purely a matter
of,
uh,
you know,
tribal,
a sentiment,
you know.
And um,
so we lose our ability to distinguish
these different projects when we say,
oh look,
you know,
fake news.
It both sides do it.
Or here's a lie.
Here's Susan Rice's one lie that she
told in the last 10 years maybe in got
caught for.
And we have a president who lies every
time he picks up his approaches a mike
or,
or picks up his twitter.
She had other problems because she had
gone on,
I believe,
on the Sunday morning talk shows after
Ben Gazi with some talking points.
Yes.
Yeah.
No,
soon as Susan look like she was itching
to get caught.
I mean,
whether this was a case of.
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
I,
I think your point is very,
very important because I think that when
you have,
um,
if you have one side that lies all the
time,
it's imperative that the other side
don't lie at all.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh.
And in the line and say,
look,
everybody does this.
Why it's a tense time for people in my
line of work because we were so much
scrutiny and then we get it wrong.
We really,
you know,
we take a lot of heat,
but when we get it wrong,
I think we're pretty quick to say we got
it wrong.
Here's the actual.
Here's the truth.
Do you know the Donald trump
junior said that cernovich get a
pulitzer for exposing Susan Rice.
Really?
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
it's a bit.
But that's it.
That's why this drives me a little crazy
because it is not cernovich is the fact
that,
that this is
why did you lead them down the Cernovich
that you just gave them right back into
its yard in front of the kit.
And we're only now discovering the
consequences of this.
Let's come back in five years,
see if,
if we're talking about anything that
makes any sense.
Well,
it's all very blurry.
It,
it really is very blurred because we've
never had a situation like this where we
have a president that people just don't
trust to be honest.
And when someone would,
if someone lied about anything in the
past,
I mean if Donald Trump got caught having
his dick sucked in the White House to my
on film and you know,
he built like,
look,
I made a mistake when he wouldn't be,
nothing would be nothing.
Photoshop did that fake news.
Just again,
just slot to use Joseph Goldstein's
phrase before about slotting into
geological time and just looking at the
broader scope of history,
you know,
we've had really,
we've had periods of time where we had
media than the muck rakers,
you know,
where the media outlets
were.
Didn't even pretend at times to,
to,
um,
to not have an agenda.
Items where those.
And the early parts of our republic
where we had was a teddy Roosevelt
called the journalists muck rakers
where,
um,
they basically,
he was saying that their job was to
write muck,
uh,
to be working in filth and uh,
the media and American politics have
been filled with instances,
American media and American politics had
been filled with instances over our
short history of a untruths and agendas.
And,
uh,
then we have times of relative
stability.
And then sometimes we slide back into
more tumultuous times.
I think maybe the Pollyanna here,
but I think that we,
the republic will survive and that we
will.
It doesn't inexorably lead to a time
where truth doesn't matter.
Well,
it seems to open up the door for a
viable alternative seems to open up the
door for someone who comes along who is
in many ways bulletproof.
It is a very ethical.
It's opened a door.
I mean,
now anyone talking to somebody to run
for office.
Yes.
I,
I just don't think anybody's bulletproof
humans.
Humans.
I mean with the exception of Joe Rogan,
but definitely not bulletproof.
You don't have to be bulletproof.
I mean,
this guy has got nothing but bullet
holes in him when he's president.
What Joe was saying is it opens the door
to somebody who's on a strong,
viable alternative for someone who is
ethical seminar.
His door is open to anyone who,
who couldn't be president at this point.
I mean,
there's no one that steps forward right
now.
I mean is,
it doesn't.
Do you think they're waiting?
I mean like who?
First of all it will say you couldn't be
president.
There was never.
Has never been an atheist.
They would attach your twitter page.
First of all,
good luck.
They would hire him.
No,
I mean I think,
you know,
if you're going to use a conventional
political calculus,
well then yeah.
Then you know,
an atheist be an atheist to having a
history of psychedelic drug use,
having edgy positions.
That alienates,
you know,
massive a constituent constituencies I,
but all of that.
A deal breaker.
But I could,
you would never have predicted that
someone this scandalous and inept and
dishonest and provably so at every.
I mean he can't.
He literally can't get through an hour
of the day without something that would
have been a scandal in some previous age
of the earth coming out of his,
his mouth.
Um,
it's just,
it's,
I think,
yeah,
I think there's no predicting who could
be a president in the future mean it's,
it's,
it's you need a,
you need wealth and you need charisma on
some level.
You need to,
you need to be able to,
to get a tribe behind you.
Um,
but I don't think you need any of what
people thought you needed even a year
ago.
Well,
what he's done by circumventing the
whole system and bay being independently
wealthy is really kinda.
But even that was a jam.
I mean that was amazing is that he is
like,
I don't know how much money he actually
put into his campaign,
but it's just not nearly what you would
have.
What you.
I mean he really only had to pretend to
be that wealthy and it was incredible.
What happened.
Like is what he achieved with very
little campaign funds and you know what
I mean,
you as a,
he,
it's like them or not,
you have to give him credit for an
unbelievable victory that very few
people saw it coming.
It's a popularity contest.
Isn't that part of the problem as you
made a popular person president of a
popularity contest?
I mean,
that's what it is.
He was,
he was running against somebody who
wasn't popular.
So that's it.
Let's put it in context.
We're always coming after eight years of
a Democratic president who was
controversial in many ways.
And it's always harder for somebody at
the same party to run.
So there are a lot of dynamics large or
impersonal dynamics that were working in
his favor.
Yeah.
It's just.
But when we get back to the argument
about like,
are we in apocalyptic times or whatever,
I guess,
and I mean,
I don't know anything,
I,
but my instinct is just as a country,
we've,
we've seen times have much worse
division.
We had a civil war.
Um,
it's telling that you have to go back
there for,
for a compelling example,
this would've been the sixties.
Yeah.
People in the streets.
We had the weather underground.
We had to,
you know,
we was pretty to what we had.
We had mlk and rfk assassinated right at
time.
Yeah.
What I'm worried about now is I think
he's truly unique and I think,
I think the,
the way we're becoming unmoored from
kind of the ordinary truth testing in
politics I think is unique.
I mean the fact that we have a president
who seen it because there's a whole
feedback mechanism and maybe trump seems
to get some of his information from info
wars and from places like info wars at
all.
Yeah.
I don't think he pays a price for,
for his,
his,
his popularity rating is not high.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He's,
he's paying some price.
But the question is,
is it going to be enough and what
happens within the next terrorist
attack?
Right.
I mean,
so,
so the real fear is that if we have a
rush dog fire kind of moment,
right,
engineered by him or not.
I mean,
I'm not so paranoid as to think he's
going to do it,
but I just think it's inevitable.
Something that's going to happen.
I mean,
we've,
we've had a,
we've had 80 days,
100 days,
whatever it's been of his presidency
were basically nothing has happened and
it's been pure chaos,
right?
And the work of governments not getting
done.
The government's barely even staffed and
this has been a period of work.
Nothing really has happened,
but imagine a nine slash 11 size event
or something really goes off the rails
with North Korea or China or Russia.
Uh,
it will be so.
I mean,
the,
the pressure when the pressure to
normalize him as commander in chief will
be much greater than it is now.
And already everyone's feeling that
pressure,
um,
but to the,
the,
the ability to clamp down on civil
liberties and um,
uh,
just,
use the power of the presidency in a way
that,
that will be very difficult for,
um,
our society to recover from.
I think it's just,
I mean,
I think the,
it's,
it's a scary moment and I'm,
I mean,
I,
I the,
the people who are drawn analogies
between him and,
you know,
the thirties in,
in,
um,
Germany.
Um,
I mean,
I think those analogies are misleading
in ways,
but again,
you just don't know how strange things
could get in with a big negative
stimulus to the system with what I think
we know is that we have someone in
charge who is a malignantly selfish
conman.
Right?
I think that is an objective fact.
That's not a partisan thing to say he
is.
I mean,
that's as obvious about him as his hair
and to have that much power in the hands
of somebody who is that,
whose,
whose ethical compass is that unreliable
or reliably bad in my view?
And I got,
I wouldn't say this if pence who scares
me for other reasons.
I mean he's a theocrat.
I wouldn't say this of,
of most Republicans who I might disagree
with,
but there's just something.
But to put that much power in the hands
of somebody who,
um,
is so disconnected from facts and a and
reasonable concern for the wellbeing of,
of the rest of humanity and the future.
And I mean it's just,
it's,
it's an incredible moment and I don't
think we've ever had a president who you
could look at and say that about.
So clearly.
I mean,
not even Nixon,
Nixon was pathological in other ways,
but you know,
Nixon Nixon was given us the clean air
act,
right.
I mean,
Nixon had some point of contact with
terrestrial reality which wasn't just
about figuring out how to,
how to burnish his,
his imaginary grander,
you know.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean,
I,
I think we're one huge news story away
from finding out how bad a president he
could be and think.
I think that's.
No,
I think
he could surprise that he could surprise
even the people who are very
pessimistic.
Well,
he could also rise to the occasion.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I see that.
Well,
no,
I mean also like to know how I would be
the first to give him or the system the
credit for that.
I mean it's like,
it's like,
it's not that I,
I,
if he starts doing something good like
let's say a massive infrastructure
project,
right.
That includes building out good things,
not coal jobs,
but you know,
if you know,
fixing bridge,
clean infrastructure.
Right,
right.
If he starts doing that,
that,
that I have no,
I mean that's,
that'd be fantastic.
Right.
And it's possible he could start doing
that for his own.
His motives wouldn't even matter
ultimately as long as he was doing the
right things.
But his motives are so reliably,
uh,
self-involved that give me what we need
is a system we need to.
Someone needs to be able to play him.
I mean,
this kind of narcissistic Glockenspiel
well enough to get him to do the things
that would be good for the world,
but I just don't see.
I just,
just,
there's just too much chaos in the
system for that to be a reliable.
Well,
like you,
they,
they try to keep him away from social
media.
Oh yeah,
well that's working out.
I mean,
that's,
that's a big thing,
don't they?
They try to pull him away from it.
Yeah.
But that's been impossible.
No one can do it.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
remember that crazy press conference
that he had like just a few weeks into
being president.
I was unbelievable.
I had,
I got text messages from friends that
are Republicans and they're like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
But you know,
there are,
it's an interesting,
um,
it's an interesting sort of Roshak test
because there are millions of Americans
who watched that press conference and
founded delightfully thought they
thought that he was killed,
but pounding on the,
on the liberal media.
Yeah.
When you read a transcript,
when you read a transcript of what
actually comes out of his mouth,
it's,
it is amazing.
I mean it,
the,
the poverty of the passages in terms of
information and I mean it's just the
fact that we have a president who speaks
like,
this is cool.
I could never have foreseen that in our
lifetime this was going to happen.
Just,
it's unimaginable to me.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people there are just
indisputable,
millions of elitist signed it,
riff league concern to.
Did you see bill Maher's
thing about Anthony Wiener that he
thinks that Anthony Wiener should run
against trump.
We need our own crazy mad anthony
wiener.
Besides his obvious addictions to
sexting with people was a very powerful
politician and a very good speaker and
he had a lot of very good quality.
Who's going after bankers?
The same as the Eliot Spitzer,
Eliot Spitzer did a lot of good things.
He was going after the bankers.
He was going after corruption and yeah,
well I've said it but that.
That's an example.
There's a flag planted that shows us how
far we have gone from the normal.
I mean Elliot Spitzer destroyed himself
with one instance of hypocrisy.
Right?
Right.
What was pretty bad?
Trump level bad.
I mean there's just no,
we don't have.
Well,
they'll pop in the law in this way.
I mean,
he was.
He was with a prostitute.
Well,
that's a stupid law.
The real problem was that he was going
after going after Ross Johnson giant.
That was the real problem is the
hypocrisy.
The hypocrisy wasn't that he did
something illegal where you paid someone
for sex,
that that law seems to me to be so
archaic and so ridiculous.
You could pay someone to massage you,
you can't pay someone to touch your
genitals.
It seems ridiculous.
But I guess the other piece you have to
put in play there is that there,
there are some percentage of people
working in the sex trade who are not
doing it voluntarily or coerced to one
another.
And that's a horror show.
And that's part of the problem with that
is that it's illegal.
I mean,
that's the big argument is that,
well,
yes there is.
There is that argument and I agree with
you that,
that it consenting adults should be able
to do what they want to do,
but the coop,
but the crucial variable there is
consent and.
Agreed.
Yes.
Um,
I just think that someone is going to
have to be dynamic.
They're gonna have to be,
they're going to have to engage people
in a way that they're going to have to
deal with his attacks.
It's case or maybe what's people will be
thirsting for after after four years is
a is actually blend.
Yeah,
right.
Maybe right?
Yeah.
I would do with land right now.
Fantastic blend at blanded.
Actually super religious would be the
might be happy for Ted Cruz and that
blend.
No,
but my enthusiasm for impeachment
suggests that I'm happy with pence.
Right.
Like so like if,
if I could find the impeachment button,
I would not hesitate to suppress it.
And pence,
given his religious commitments,
you know,
a few short years ago would've been
among my worst nightmares.
I mean I would be talking about the rise
of the Christian.
Right.
And the danger of theocracy and I mean
his,
but he's a psychologically he seems like
a normal,
predictable,
solid American compared to what we have.
Isn't the other question like trump's
age,
he's a 70 year old man.
People don't really live that much past
70,
especially people that are overweight
and people that don't exercise all to
healthy.
And that campaign was,
I can't believe.
I mean that's his energy and his credit.
Yeah,
I mean that's an amazing thing to be
able to do.
How do you think it's most punishing
thing in the world?
I can't even imagine.
Schedule is always having a good time.
Seriously did and in that press
conference we're talking about
[inaudible] 77,
I think it was 77 minutes press
conference.
He looked like he was having a blast.
Yeah,
he gets like he gets really energized.
I mean that's.
It's got to be the most punishing,
beat down ever if you're,
if you're not designed for it.
I mean I can't imagine how tiring.
I'd never done a campaign.
I mean you get exhausted for 30 minutes
of looking at your,
at mentions
now you have to be wired differently,
but you know,
he clearly is,
is he's wired that way.
It's worked for them.
But you need someone who's willing to
submit to the punishment of running and
that's a rare person or it's not.
And the problem is that kind of selects
or things that you don't actually want
in a president or at least I wouldn't
think you would want.
I mean,
it's Aleks for kind of narcissism and a
sense that,
that really has to be you,
right?
It doesn't,
that doesn't select for the normal
intellectual space.
You,
you're constantly aware,
aware of the ways in which you are not
the best guy or gal to be doing the
thing,
right?
Like you want to defer to experts and,
and um,
you know,
trump is only I can fix it,
right?
And that worked.
And so you need something of that that
creeps into the,
um,
the headspace of most politicians it
seems.
And,
and,
um,
so scientific humility and I'm just a
kind of a sense of the limits of,
of any one person's expertise is not
necessarily the right piece of software
to have running at when it comes time to
run for president.
Now I wanna switch gears a little bit.
It's not,
it's not totally related,
but it is in somewhat in some ways,
headspace.
I'm talking about mindsets and talking
about like we've brought this up but
really haven't delved into it much at
all about meditation and about how much
it's affected you and how it got you
back on track.
And I know that you're a big proponent
of it and I am as well,
although I think I'd probably do it
differently than you guys do,
but I'd love to hear how you do it by
using an isolation tank.
Oh really?
Like a sensory deprivation tank.
Yeah.
And I do a lot of yoga.
Those are,
those are two big ones for me.
You know,
I think those alone have straightened
out my brain in a great way.
Yoga in particular,
Yoga,
because it's,
um,
it's not yoga forces you to do it.
You're either doing it or you're not
doing it.
There's no room for distraction.
You know,
you're,
you're essentially forced to deal with
what these poses require of you.
And I think that in doing so and having
a singular focus of trying to maintain
your and stretch and extend and do all
these different things while you do it,
then concentrating almost entirely on
your breath,
which is a big factor in yoga that it
has remarkable brain scrubbing
attributes.
Yeah.
I would say,
and I don't know much before I say this,
let me just ask,
what are you doing in the isolation
tank?
Like what are you doing in your mind a
lot?
Well,
you know,
do you use it for
a bunch of different in a bunch of
different ways.
I don't use it as much as I should
honestly.
Um,
but I concentrate on and sometimes I go
in there with an idea,
like I'll concentrate on material like
that I'm working on or maybe Jujitsu
techniques that I'm having problems with
or some other things I'm dealing with,
you know,
any,
any sort of issues that I have.
Sometimes I do that sometimes it just go
in there and chill out and relax and
breathe and concentrate.
There's a lot of physical things that
happen inside the tank is the amount of
magnesium in the water because it's
epsom salts.
It's really good for you physically.
It's very good for the muscles.
It loosens you up and relaxes you and
that eliminates a lot of stress.
And that physical elimination of stress
allows the brain to function with just
less pressure and allows you to relax
more and put things in perspective
better.
And it also,
it gives you this environment that's not
available anywhere else in the planet.
This weightless floating,
disconnected from your body environment
where you're.
You don't hear anything,
you don't see anything,
you don't feel anything.
You feel like you're weightless.
You,
you have this sensation of flying
because you're totally weightless,
weightless in the dark.
You Open your eyes,
you don't see anything,
you close your eyes.
It's exactly the same.
The water's the same temperature as your
skin so you don't feel the water and you
floating.
I'll say this,
I don't know how this is going to have
to go down.
I actually don't have any questions
about the,
the,
the benefits of being in an isolation
tank even though I don't know too much
about it.
And I also am a PR.
I think yoga is great,
although I don't do much of it myself.
I,
I think though that there may actually
be a difference between those two
activities and meditation because it a
kind of highfalutin term metacognition,
sort of knowing what you know or knowing
that you're thinking that happens in the
kind of mindfulness meditation of which,
uh,
Sam and I are proponents proponents that
I think is a different thing where
you're seeing.
And I'll just try to put this in
English.
When you're meditating the way we do,
you're seeing how crazy you are.
You're sitting,
you're fucking nuts,
and that actually has a real value.
Is systematic collision with the asshole
in your head has a real value because
when the asshole offers you up a shitty
suggestion in the rest of your life,
which is basically it's job like,
oh yeah,
you should eat the 17th cookie or say
the thing that's going to ruin the next
48 hours of your marriage or whatever.
You're better able to resist it.
So what,
like what do you do?
So I mean the basic steps of mindfulness
meditation or to sit.
Most people close their eyes.
You bring your full attention,
the feeling of your breath.
Just the,
you're not thinking about your breath,
just feeling the raw data of the
physical sensations,
and then the third step is the Biggie,
which is as soon as you try to do this,
your mind's going to go bonkers.
You're going to start thinking about
what's for lunch to an eight,
a haircut,
where did your bills run wild,
whatever,
blah,
blah.
You're just going to notice,
oh,
I'm my mind's going crazy right now.
But that noticing is the key moment is
the fact that victory.
It's interesting because this is when
most people think they failed that
because,
oh,
I can't meditate because I can't clear
my mind.
This is the,
the biggest misconception about
meditation.
You do not need to clear your mind.
That's impossible unless you're
enlightened or dead.
Uh,
the whole goal is just to notice when
you've become distracted and start
again.
You return your attention to your breath
and you just do that a million times and
every time you catch yourself wondering
and go back to your breath,
it's a bicep curl for your brain.
It changes your brain and that over time
creates the kind of Meta cognition I was
discussing before where you see that
you're a homo sapiens sapiens another
word zero,
a,
that's how we're classified as a
species,
the one who thinks and knows he or she
thinks and that just that knowing that
you have this voice in your head,
uh,
as Sam likes to joke,
he feels like when he thinks about the
voice in his head,
he feels like he's been hijacked by the
most boring person alive.
Just says the same shit over and over.
I'm a,
a joke that I deal from them all the
time.
Yeah.
Uh,
that,
that is enormously powerful because then
you are not held hostage by this voice.
A similar thing happens in the tank.
Um,
I do a do a form of meditation,
that tank.
Sometimes when I go in there with or
without an idea,
like if I'm not working on material or
anything else where I just concentrating
on my breath in through the nose,
out through the mouth,
and I just literally concentrate on the
breath.
And the same thing happens to
meditation.
Meditation.
It's similar,
it's the exact same thing.
The difference is in the tank.
After Awhile,
after about 20 minutes or so,
that breaks loose to psychedelic states.
Wow.
Have you ever combined the tank with
psychedelics?
Altered state,
so yeah.
Yeah.
Sweat trip.
What?
LSD or mushrooms?
Mushrooms,
but the big one is edible pot.
Edible pod seems to be as strong as
anything in there.
Like I've got enough pot where I'm
convinced I'm going to die,
then I climb in there and every time I
do it I go,
don't do that again.
So just get out.
So terrified
your motivation when you're eating the
pot and climbing into.
We'll see what happens.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just be scared.
Be terrified.
Yeah.
Because nothing ever happens.
You never die,
but God damn you just convinced that the
universe is imploding around you and
that it just.
So it usually has the,
the character of fear being part of it.
It's also not embracing the fear,
not letting the fear run rampant and
just sort of relaxing and giving into
the vulnerability,
your,
the finite of your existence
and just breathing and concentrating and
letting.
Letting the dance take place because
there's some.
There's some sort of a weird that one of
the things that there's a big
misconception about when it comes to
edible pot,
is it edible pod is like smoking pot.
It's an entirely different process.
Physiologically.
Your liver time course is very different
to it.
We can stay stolen for three days.
Yeah.
You,
you could fuck up and eat too many
brownies and you'll be gone for a long
time.
That sounds miserable.
It is,
but it's not because he gets something
out of it when it's over the.
The process is excruciating,
but when you come out of it,
you just feel so happy.
Feel so happy.
It's over.
Is it like the joke about the dude is
banging his head up against the wall and
somebody says,
why are you doing that?
He says,
because it feels so good when I stopped
in a way,
but there's no physical damage banging
your head up against the wall.
You're going to hurt yourself.
This is true.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
I think there seems like there might be
easier ways to get to the same wisdom.
Maybe,
but I think there's also creativity that
gets inspired by the edible pot,
something called 11 hydroxy metabolite
that your body produces.
It's so different than most people when
they eat pot,
they think they been dosed like anybody
who smoked pot before and then you give
them a Brownie.
They think,
oh my God,
there something in that,
and they're convinced because reality
itself just seems like it just dissolves
and especially inside the tank,
there's something about the tank
environment that produces.
In the absence of any external stimuli,
your brain becomes sort of supercharged
because what you're trying to do when
you're just sitting down and
concentrating and relaxing as you're
trying to focus on your thoughts,
but you're still aware of your body.
You're still aware of your elbows
touching this desk,
your butt touching the chair.
There's all these different factors that
are that are.
There's stimuli that's coming into your
senses.
Whereas in the tank there's none of that
virtually.
It's almost completely eliminated.
There's some,
but you can.
You can.
You could phase that stuff out,
like you could still feel the water a
little bit.
If you think about it,
you could still use,
sometimes you bump into the wall and you
have to like center yourself and you
have to relax again and make sure you're
not moving so you don't touch things
which can kind of dissolve the
experience,
their experiences,
meditation where you have that same
experience where you lose your sense of
the body,
but that usually comes with more
concentration.
You have to be very concentrated on it.
I feel like you would have that
experience and it would be even more
intense if you did the exact same thing
that you do outside the tank in the
tank.
I don't think you need any psychedelics
and the tangle.
It's one thing that I tell people when
they ask me,
should I get high before I do it?
I'm like,
no,
just do it.
Just do it.
If you decide after a while,
if you've done it three or four times,
you was like,
I wonder what it's like if I just take a
little bit of a hit of pot and see where
it takes me and there's nothing wrong
with that.
It's not going to hurt you,
and if you're a type of person who
enjoys marijuana or whatever,
but the tank alone by itself,
just the absence of sensory input,
your brain goes to a very,
very different place and as long as you
can relax and as long as you don't think
too much about the fact that you're in
the tank,
just concentrate entirely on your
thoughts entirely on your breath.
And again,
let all those crazy like where to
hamsters live like all that shit.
Let let all that stuff run wild through
your mouth,
but I feel like in the tank at least
that gets to a certain spot.
Then it stops existing and then the
psychedelic state takes over.
Yeah,
well it depends on what the goal is.
I think there can be many different
goals of meditation or quasi spiritual
practice and they're not there.
They're distinct.
So the center of the Bullseye for me is
not suffering unnecessarily.
Right?
So.
And so one thing that,
that mindfulness gives you is so it's
potentially,
it's compatible with every experience
you can have.
I mean,
there's is nothing in your experience
that isn't inappropriate object of
meditation.
You just,
most people start with the breath
because it's just a very convenient
thing to start with,
but once you know how to do this
particular practice,
you're just,
your goal is to just be clearly aware of
whatever your experience is in each
moment.
So it's emotions arise,
thoughts arise,
sounds come in your,
your attention is wide open to whatever
your experience is.
So it's not like.
So.
Nothing in principle is a distraction.
I mean that could be,
you can be meditating right next to a
construction site and the sound of the
hammers is just as good and object of
meditation as the breath or anything
else.
So there's nothing.
Everything is included,
but the,
the,
the superpower you're after,
which you actually can acquire through
this practice is to realize that
virtually all of your,
of your psychological suffering and
actually arguably,
virtually all of your,
your physical suffering or the
difference between physical pain and
suffering,
which I mean,
those two are not quite the same thing.
Um,
is a matter of being lost in thought as
a matter of thinking,
without knowing that you're thinking and
what and what mindfulness does.
And really any technique of meditation
ultimately should do,
is teach you to break the spell of being
lost in thought and to notice a thought
as a thought.
I mean the,
the,
the huge difference is until you learn
how to meditate or do something like
meditation,
you're just helplessly thinking every
moment of your life,
you're having a conversation with
yourself.
You're having content,
whether it's images,
stick or linguistic,
poor forth into consciousness,
every moment and so incessantly that you
don't even notice it.
It's just white noise.
And not only does it completely color
your experience moment to moment.
So like if you're,
if they're angry thoughts,
you're angry.
If they're depressed thoughts or you're
depressed or sad that you're sad.
So you become your thoughts,
but you also feel,
you feel,
you feel identified,
you feel that you are the thinker of
your thoughts.
You feel like a self and it's completely
structured by this flow of,
of mentation every moment and it
produces everything you do.
It produces all of your intentions and
your goals and your actions,
and he said this about me and now I'm
going to say that.
I mean,
so it's like it's everything coming out
of you is born of of this same process
and meditation is a way of recognizing
that consciousness and then what you are
subjectively as a prior condition of
just be awareness in which everything is
showing up,
sounds,
sensations and thoughts and thoughts can
become just other objects of
consciousness and I'm so I'm going to
take eva,
Eva,
at a very basic example of the
difference between between pain and
suffering.
You can feel very strong physical pain,
I mean unpleasant pain and just be aware
of it in that sense that it's unbearable
is virtually always untrue because you
in that moment,
you've already born it,
right?
That may,
that the feeling that something's
unbearable is really the fear of having
to experience it in the next moment in
the future.
Right?
Because you're almost like if some.
If someone drives a nail into your knee,
right?
You might only.
That's a.
That sounds like it's unbearable,
but every moment you're feeling it,
you're burying it,
right?
It's like,
it's,
it's what you're,
what you're thinking about is the last
moment and the next moment.
Then you're thinking about how much you
know,
when am I going to get some relief and
you know,
what's the cure and how badly is my knee
injured?
And you know,
like you're,
you're,
you're worried about the future
continuously and you're not noticing the
automaticity of thought that is,
that is amplifying the,
the,
the negative negativity of the
experience in that moment.
And we all know that you can have super
intense sensation which is either either
pleasant or unpleasant depending on the,
on the conceptual frame you've put
around it.
So for instance,
if,
if you had this massive sense of
soreness in your shoulder that you would
experience it very differently if it was
a,
the result of you dead lifting more than
you ever had in your life and you were
proud of it,
right?
Be probably cancer.
And you're waiting for your,
you know,
the,
the biopsy results.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
you're worried about this is the thing,
the thing is going to kill you or you're
getting raw for some deep tissue massage
and it hurts like hell,
but you actually totally understand the
source of the pain and you know,
it's going to be gone the moment the guy
pulls his elbow back,
right?
So it could be the exact same sensation
each one of those,
but the conceptual frame you have around
it totally dictates the level of
psychological suffering and,
or the or
the can dictate the total absence of
psychological suffering.
Now we were talking before the podcast
started about your apps and we were
talking about the amount of different
meditation exercises on the APP.
So like what kind of different
meditation exercises are there?
If you're talking about just
concentrating on mindfulness and
breathing,
uh,
as it turns out,
you can iterate off of that basic
exercise a in some to,
to like a infinity essentially because
you talk about not only will I lose my,
I don't want to get too ahead of myself,
but basically the,
the,
the basic instructions are that we
listed before.
You're feeling your breath coming in and
then when you get lost,
you start again,
but then you can add onto that.
So one big thing to add on is something
called mental noting,
so you're breathing in and out,
you're feeling your breath,
and then you get distracted by a huge
wave of anger.
Generally speaking,
when we get hit by a wave of anger,
we just inhabit the anger.
We become angry.
There's no buffer between the stimulus
and our response to it,
but there's this little technique you
can do of just making a little mental
note of,
Oh,
that's anger.
And that kind of objectifies the thing.
It's a little bit like pressing the
picture and picture button on your
remote control where the story that's
taken up,
the whole frame can be seen with some,
uh,
perspective.
Uh,
so that's just one example of the little
techniques that you can add onto the
basic exercise.
And you can go for a long time.
So as we were discussing Sam's about to
start his meditation APP,
which is going to be called what sent
waking up,
waking up.
And I have mine,
which is called 10 percent happier.
Sam is going to be doing all the
teaching on his APP and my,
on my absence.
I'm not a teacher.
We have experts coming in like Joseph
Goldstein,
who's again the friend of a friend of
both Sam and I,
um,
a and you,
each teacher has their own emphasis and
you then start talking about applied
meditation.
So how do I use it when we're,
how do I use in my everyday life?
How do I use it if really what I want to
do right now is,
um,
control my eating.
So meditation,
for example,
we have a course on the APP that talks
about using it to not overeat.
By the way,
I'm terrible at this,
but you can use your ability,
your mindfulness,
your ability to know what's happening in
your head in any given moment without
getting carried away by it to not
overeat.
Notice,
Oh,
I'm having this urge right now to eat as
I did last night in entire bag of melted
chocolate in my hotel room.
Uh,
but I don't,
I can ride that urge and not do the
thing that I know is stupid.
Um,
so anyway,
that's just a little taste of how you
can take meditation and bring it in
numerous directions.
Do
you guys feel competitive?
Both of apps now isn't even out yet?
No,
not yet.
When he comes out and completely
cannibalize cannibalizes
men both then yeah.
How happy is for me 10 percent happier.
I'll be like negative 100 percent.
What's 10 percent of zero?
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
I actually think I'm of the view,
you know,
now that I've been in this meditation
APP business for a little while,
I'm kind of,
I don't think it's Uber,
I don't think the business model is that
there's just one huge app that everybody
uses and maybe there's some distant,
you know,
second,
I actually think it's more,
a little bit more like fast food.
I think it's going to be a bunch of big
players and uh,
in,
you may switch back and forth.
Um,
and so I think it's just one need a nap.
No,
no,
no you don't.
But I mean,
the thing that's useful and it's really
useful at any level of expertise in,
in meditation and that at least this
kind of meditation is having someone
guide you.
Yeah,
it's,
it's like a a mindfulness alarm that's
constantly going off,
going off and you know,
periodically over the course of 10
minutes or 20 minutes or however long
you're sitting and because distraction
is just continually the problem and
you're either meditating or you're
distracted.
You're either,
you're either aware of what's happening
at that moment or you're lost in
thought.
And that's true throughout your life.
I mean,
you're either hearing what I'm saying
right now,
or you're thinking about something else
and you don't know it,
right?
Or you're.
You're either reading the book you're
intending to read or your mind is
wandering.
You're going to have to read that
paragraph again.
So this,
this failure to concentrate,
this failure to be able to focus on what
you're intending to focus on.
Is it just this,
this universal problem of human
consciousness.
And so meditation trains that and other
benefits follow,
but the having a voice in your head
reminding you that you're even
attempting to be meditating is a very
powerful,
even if you're,
even if it's your own voice.
I mean,
even when I'm listening to a meditation
that I recorded,
just my own voice,
remember it reminded me that I'm,
that I'm supposed to be meditating.
It works like any other voice,
you know,
and it's um,
so it's,
it's just,
it's a feedback system that you can't
really provide for yourself,
although you,
obviously you can,
I mean,
you can meditate without an app and most
people do.
I mean,
I've spent very little time meditating
with apps.
I just think they're very useful.
But you see,
both of us started meditating.
I started meditating well before I did,
but we both started pre worn around.
Um,
uh,
so the,
you can read,
you can read a book,
read a good book and learn how to
meditate out of the book and just
basically remember the basic
instructions and do it.
Uh,
but a really is useful to have an APP,
especially for some people because one
of the biggest problems in meditation is
this persistent fear that you're not
doing it right.
And so to have a voice you in your ear
just giving you,
reminding you of the basic instructions
which are so simple but very easy to
forget.
It can be very useful.
I like the idea of it being like bicep
curls for your mind.
Yeah,
I mean,
you see,
you see it in the brain scans and no
Samuel correct me where I run a foul of
scientific accuracy here,
but this base,
this,
this simple act of sitting,
trying,
trying to focus on one thing at a time.
And then when you get distracted knowing
you're distracted and returning to your
breath is changing your brain.
When you do that,
you're boosting a,
the muscles.
Uh,
the obviously the muscles.
I'm using a,
a light loosely.
You're boosting your focus muscle and in
many cases,
whether there was a study in 2010,
I think it was done at Harvard,
uh,
that took,
people would never meditated before and
they scanned their brains and then they
had them do eight weeks of a,
I think,
a half hour a day of meditation.
The end of the eight weeks they scanned
their brains again.
What they found was in the area of the
brain associated with self awareness,
the gray matter group,
and in the area of the brain associated
with stress,
the gray matter shrink.
That to me is pretty compelling.
That is beautiful.
Gentlemen.
We just did three hours.
Wow.
Flew by.
Yes,
it did.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
All right,
everybody.
That's it.
Go do something else.
No.